the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
you don't need money and you don't need
Fame to enjoy the U.S women's and U.S
open championships in St Louis tail
lenders need to burn Rubber to catch the
leaders or watch their future title
chances disappear lightning struck for a
Wonder Liang who clocked Lavon aroni
into catapult into a two-way time per
second behind front-runner Fabiano
caruana Jennifer Yu bullied her way past
the group at second after outboxing
former champ Sabina foiser for Clear
lead in the women's section the rest day
is over now it's time to get back to the
chessboards day six of Timeless chess
coming up next
[Music]
all right
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day six of the
2022 us chess championships and U.S
women's chess Championships held at the
St Louis chess club is the day after the
rest day and the players are
re-energized recalibrated and ready to
battle over the chessboard let's go to
the studio and start this exciting round
with yasu and Anastasia from the home of
Chess in the United States welcome to
the St Louis chess club and the sixth
round of the USGS championships in the
U.S women's chess championships
hello everyone I'm Anastasia karlovic
and I'm joined by my awesome co-host
Grandmaster yes sir Sarah you stole my
word I loved I love the Yellow Jacket
thank you nice to be with you after the
rest day hello everyone thank you for
joining our show indeed the rest day was
much needed as our Gladiators are about
to renew their hostilities but first
Anastasia do the honors and tell us
about the leaders let's start with the
ladies
so we have the Soul Leader in the
tournament Jennifer Yu was four points
out of five she leads the field and then
Arena crochet time U.S Champion has
three and a half points as well as
tativa Brahman and Ellis Lee and in the
open section and in the open section we
have Fabiano caruana with three and a
half points he leads the field same
seven follows his steps with 3.7 who is
as a Wonder Liang and defending Champion
Wesley so and the gangsters at 50 and
about our format for these two national
championships each Championship has 14
players and they play round robin
tournaments 90 minutes for the first 40
moves followed by 30 minutes for the
rest of the game and we have 30 seconds
increment from move one no drawers
fighting until the end I certainly
enjoyed the rest day but what about our
remaining schedule
and we have five rounds to go starting
from today around 6 11th of October and
the rest day the next one will be on
16th of October and if we have playoffs
we'll have them on 20th of October as
well as closing ceremony wonderful and
Christian good to see you in studio are
you all replenished and refreshed ready
to talk about the upcoming battles oh
absolutely it's great to be back in the
studio and it's definitely great to be
back in business here at the US chess
championships and before the rest day I
highlighted one of our leaders the
leader in the open section that is
Fabiano caruana but right now I want to
highlight the lady that is Making Waves
in the U.S women's chess championships
and of course I'm talking about our
leader woman Grand Master Jennifer Yu
she started off a blazing hot with two
uh devastating victories in the first
couple of games but after that a setback
a
nevertheless she came to the studio
after that after her round four Victory
and she said yes I was looking for
revenge in round number four and five
she managed to take down Sophie Maury's
Suzuki and Sabina for sure and right now
is in the soul leadership position and
let's take a look at her career
highlights as well well this young lady
is so accomplished and she's only 20
years of age in 2018 she was awarded the
woman Grand Master title in 2019 she
became the U.S women's champion scoring
10 out of 11 at only 17 years of age she
wasn't even an adult yet right now she
is 20 years of age and she is attending
she's a sophomore actually at Harvard
University needless to say this young
lady is impressing everybody here at the
U.S women's chess championships and uh
if you've been living under a rock and
you haven't seen all the interviews
we've done here at the Championships
well take a look because we've had a lot
of fun once we are with Hans Neiman
after an incredible Victory with the
black pieces against a fellow Junior
Christopher U Hans first of all let's
address the elephant in the room you've
been under a lot of pressure tell us a
bit about that well um I think that this
game is a his message to everyone and uh
you know this entire thing started with
me saying chess speaks for itself and uh
I think this game spoke for itself and
showed the chess player that I am and it
also showed that um I'm not going to
back down and I'm going to play my best
chess here regardless of the pressure
that I'm under and that's all I have to
say about this game and
you know
chess speaks for itself you know that's
all I can say let's discuss the game a
little bit that's it but uh you know you
can leave it to your interpretation but
thank you that is that's it all you want
to say I'd like to say yes because I'm
such a beautiful game I don't even need
to describe it
thank you
Christopher this is the biggest win of
your career how do you feel you just
took down the defending U.S Champion
with the black pieces
I feel like it's a great Redemption from
yesterday
especially after after seeing the
interview and everything I felt like I
was kind of disrespected and it was also
kind of a wake-up call that I really
needed to improve my openings and
everything how did you feel after that
game yesterday because you had your
chances as well right and there's some
rivalry between you and Hans it seals I
just I felt disrespected on every level
that was a lot of fun I have to say guys
seeing this uh young players come up and
open up with uh their interviews it was
a lot of fun we've had a lot of fun they
are having a lot of fun it seems uh as
well and today let's wait and see maybe
the preparation during the rest they
will speak for itself there you go as we
see the players in line for the security
check all being wanted but I like the
pugnacious approach by our pugilists as
they throw the patties in their
commentaries and as we get ready for
this around six uh Anastasia please uh
do the honors tell our audience
what they can expect for today's
pairings starting with the ladies so we
have very important clash between the
leaders Jennifer you the sole leader of
the term place with Alice Lee who is so
tight for the second place it's very
important big ground absolutely yes
again and also we have Arena Crush who
has three and a half points playing
against Thalia Cervantes who's
undefeated with plus uh five draws yes
exactly and then 30 of Abrahim plays
against Sarita
by the way having won a game after
starting with a draw and three losses
and in the open section what parents can
we expect here we have a clash of
youngsters right I mean at the bottom
there Place against Jeffrey strong and
also a Wonderland Place against
Christopher you really important games
for them absolutely Fabiano our
tournament leader playing against the
open uh winner Alshon more
I'll stay with elshon big Clash of
giants between Wesley and Lanier Hans
Neiman versus Ray Robinson and of course
they're gonna oh there we see uh Alice
Lee getting ready for her opponent to be
wandered through just smiling she's
enjoying her her place second place in
the U.S championships it's great and the
LED for a bit of the way there too as we
see Fabi with his coffee cup getting
ready a Wonder Liang having caught
um LaVon in some pretty nasty opening
preparations he's smiling yeah he's got
a big smile really good move he knows
yeah he's suspected you know something
too as well uh three weeks of Fighting
Chess uh in these national championships
in terms of prize funds what are they
battling for tell us about the ladies
price fund
so we have actually the total price fund
for both of it is more than 400 000
which is very very impressive so for a
really main event we have 160 a thousand
and five hundred dollars uh price fund
and then for the first place it's forty
thousand and then third twenty really
great prices wonderful all the way down
to 14 and 3 000 everybody take surprise
home and in the open section and in the
open section we have 262
000 price fund and then we have 60 for
the first place 45 for the second
certified for the third one really great
great prices for the tournament and no
Fisher Price for anyone as no perfect
places
however Jennifer you as Christian was
showing had unknown draws just she
hasn't won them all as the clocks are
getting uh pressed and the game's
underway it looks like whoa whoa whoa
yeah uh our tournament leader is saying
look
you're the open Champion but uh
I want an open Sicilian I think he has
to uh with the black pieces Fabiano
caruana there is he needs to play for a
win in uh this one because why not
you're playing against the lowest rated
player in the event he's been taking
some hits
he just uh lost if I'm not saying
against Sam Shanklin in the previous
round so he's he actually lost the last
three we've been told so he's been
taking some hits his confidence levels
are at an all-time low it seems like and
Fabiano caruana needs to take advantage
of that he could potentially uh take a
huge leap forward towards that elusive
Championship true that oh what you just
said and it's it's always nice to think
yes I'm going to take advantage of the
player who's got this Target on his back
on the other hand sometimes it means
that you start to play a expenses
defenses that may not be to your liking
in the sense that it's not your a
defense game which may bring a draw
something like the Petra for example but
with this move with this move order I
wanted to ask you what exactly is it in
this particular move order a Christian
that Fabi is trying for this time enough
move order there's no C2 C4 there is no
C4 there's no Roxy bind on the board no
no no so he started off with A6 and then
Knight C6 immediately putting some
pressure in the center yeah C4 I think
it's a bit too loose I think you're
going to have to deal with ideas of
Queen two uh B6 even Bishop to C5 and
you're going to have some problems
semantic dandight on a D4 that could be
problematic so after Knight to C3 which
makes a lot of sense not Queen to C7
we've seen that quite a lot of times
Knight to F6 is uh also a move but if
you wanted to put the Knight on F6 early
on then you should have probably started
with a move Knight to F6 Knight to C3
and then Knight to C6 which by the way
Fabiano actually did it quite a few
times in his career as well so right now
he's playing with uh this A6 move and
I'm trying to remember and I think I've
seen Fabiano actually himself as saying
at this early G4 if I'm not mistaken
between
um himself and Richie Rapport I might be
mistaken and I don't see it in the
database so we'll be researching that
but I remember this move G4 came on the
board a very early aggressive move G4
what are you going to do are you going
to get the Knight to F6 probably not
because I'm ready to attack it with G5
so now it seems like the Knight has to
be committed to E7 which leads to
completely different uh type of
positions than what were usually
accustomed to in this type of Sicilians
Knight to E7 then the Knight most likely
is going to jump towards G6 or we're
going to see an ideas of I takes D4 and
the other Knight comes back to C6 so
it's going to be quite an interesting uh
middle game and I have to say a very
aggressive middle game but Fabiano has
played this with the white pieces
recently so he definitely has some
residual Knowledge from his high level
preparation and players it seems like
are still coming in we see uh us Neiman
getting wanted right now Jeffrey Sean we
see Krista for you in the back getting
uh through the first stage of the
checkups right I saw in the game between
a Wonder Liang I wonder had made his
opening move as white no response by
Christopher you and now we know why
exactly like you absolutely no but this
check is really really it takes time yes
and I was there just 20 minutes ago just
to have this experience how is it going
I didn't hide anything this time but I
promised I will do next time so it's
really sensitive and thereby there's a
really like very well equipped like I
can make sure that at any time even if
they see the ring or something
immediately it reacts the equipment so I
mean we had some checks here so it's
tomorrow Yasser is your turn okay I'm
ready for it
and uh Alice is like come on uh Jennifer
get in here I hate
I I hate uh leading on getting clock
time for free yes yes I'm like a fair
game
actually I always enjoyed that as a
player is because I wasn't usually an
early arrival I loved that in the
Olympics the olympiads uh also getting
wanted in the security checks in those
cases are can be really brutal so when
you're on time and the clock starting
this could be worth five times
it starts to feel good I remember there
was a time when during the Olympus when
there was a zero tolerance Rule and some
players were related then you get the
full points yeah you could just get
forfeited my goodness Livonia Roni and
my pick to win the open tournament has
really gotten off to the worst art he
could in his maiden voyage and this U.S
championships his first time debutante
40 years young celebrated his 40th
birthday started with four draws and a
loss well that will not get you anywhere
near the podium he's got a really first
of all
win yes and really he's got the white
pieces today against the lower rated
player darush but darush is nobody's
punching bag this is a really uh
dangerous opponent in fact and let's see
what Lavon with his usual tutorial uh
Splendor I'm guessing that's a denim yes
it's open right so it he has a t-shirt
underneath it yes exactly I was
wondering what is what is there but now
he closed it with his hand
it is a cloudy day in uh
[Laughter]
first time actually yes let's see he's
played this uh move order this kind of
uh it's it's not a Queen's Gambit
declined just yet uh he hasn't uh
definitively played the move d2d4 after
move for example like Bishop E7 you
could get a kind of a Queen's Gambit
declined uh the bishop B4 here it loses
its impact uh when there's no Pawn on D4
so for example
after a move like Castle Queen C2
castles again just notice for the moment
that the pawn isn't on D4 which means
that after B4 and Bishop B2 the diagonal
is exactly still open and that can be
very very useful for that dark squared
Bishop at the moment on uh C1 I like
this I like the choice by darush C7 C6
in fact I like it a lot having already
committed the pawn to E6 many many times
black is looking to play takes on C4 B5
B4 develop Theon Shadow His bishop and
play for C5 and this really kind of
takes the impact away after White's move
order after d497 you transposed into the
very very familiar territory of the
Moran variation and white with his kg
tricky opening play is not getting any
benefits what has caught your attention
Christian I've been uh digging deeper
into this game between Alshon and
Fabiano caruana and trying to understand
the intricacies of this opening Knight
to C6 A6 and now actually not the move
G4 which we were predicting or
anticipating and he played the move
Bishop to F4 quite an interesting
approach and we've been seeing this a
lot at the elite level as well
specifically if I'm not mistaken Richie
Rapport himself played this type of
ideas now obviously it is aimed at
taking as much control over the dark
squares D6 C7 in particular for example
there's a very nice strap if you play
the very natural Knight to E7 you want
to go to G6 attack the bishop take
advantage of uh this parallel situation
perlas position of the bishopone F4 well
yeah good luck wow Knight to B5 and now
you're actually in big big danger you
have to take take Queen to A5 but after
Bishop to D2 this Knight is going to
land on D6 with devastating consequences
I'm going to go 96 Knight takes F7
Knight takes h8 black is not completely
lost but he's not doing well either so
you have to be very very careful now
let's see what Fabiano did D6 makes a
lot of sense Bishop to F4 D6 is the
natural response now I'm starting to
support the move E5 and the main line
goes with Knight takes C6 in this
position Knight takes b66 Queen to D2
but now after E5 Bishop to G5 and by the
way this was a very high Elite level
game between uh Ari antari and Magnus
Carlson now let's take a look at how
that developed Castle H6 you don't want
to go drop back to E3 because without
the pawn on F3 after Knight to G4 your
Bishop is going to be lost I'm going to
enjoy uh the bishop pair as black and
that's going to be bad news for white so
you don't want to allow that you want to
go to H4 but take a look at this bishop
to E6 F3 F3 was not played in that one
you still have to find ways to control
this G4 square and potentially uh
develop your pieces and try to get G4
going and an offensive on the king side
the problem is after not Queen to A5 but
actually A5 was played in that one
you're missing this bishop this dark
Square Bishop on E3 and controlling a
lot of squares on the queen side
specifically this B6 so what Black's
idea is especially with this move A5 is
after Rook to B8 I'm going to go Queen
to B6 I'm going to force you to weaken
your position with the move B3
specifically because this bishop is no
longer patrolling this Ace 7 G1 diagonal
and the square B6 and that's actually
going to be bad news for your King's
safety because I'm going to go at some
point A4 break it down break the queen
side down and you're going to have uh
difficulties defending the position so
let's see what elshon came with after
the move D6 and by the way this was
played instantaneously Bishop to G3 a
very nice prophylactic move now you
might wonder what is the idea behind
this move uh Bishop to G3 well first of
all if you go Knight to F6 after Knight
takes C6 B6 and Knight to F6 actually
has been played quite a few times but it
doesn't seem to be good because I go
with E5 and now we understand why this
bishop is much better placed on a G3
than on F4 because after the move Knight
to D5 with the bishopone F4 I wouldn't
have time to take on D6 right now with
the bishopone G3 you're not attacking my
bespawn A4 I take on D6 you take back I
go Knight to E4 and I'm taking a a lot
of control over the dark squares if you
are forced to take on G3 yeah thank you
very much you're going to have huge
problems on the H file you can Castle
but Bishop to D3 is coming queen to H5
is coming as well you are in danger
right so you have to be very careful
with the black pieces Bishop to G3 I
really like this move it has been played
quite a few times if you go Bishop to E7
then I'm going to be spending another uh
move and I'm not going to commit the
Queen's position because what you're
trying to do is actually take on D4 and
win a Tempi and I followed that up with
the move E5 so what I'm going to do I'm
going to go Bishop to E2 not Queen to D2
but Bishop to e to wait for you ask you
what is your next useful move in the
position once again Knight F6 I take on
C6 and go E5 that's the key idea behind
this development with Bishop to F4 and
Bishop to G3 L Sean well he seems to
have been well prepared and has
anticipated the strategy energy coming
from Fabiano's side a very aggressive
strategy coming from Fabiano's side with
this Sicilian with E6 he had the full
day to prepare you probably spent the
whole day
absolutely he's putting some early
pressure and we don't see this very
often right it's usually far behind or
that goes super deep with his opening
preparation and usually takes uh his
opponents into deep Waters well now is
the case that he's on the defensive side
of that equation it seems to be uh first
of all thank you Christian it seems to
be the day of the Tai manov Sicilian
Christian I'd like to bring your
attention to the game between a Wonder
Liang and Christopher you for just a
moment because that game has quite a
number of differences and similarities
yes and that's actually the game between
carwana and report but not the one from
the candidates a different one 100 sure
where that game was played maybe
Bucharest it might have been Bucharest
oh yes it was in Bucharest we actually
did analysis of it
I remember
again
there's been so many games being played
uh this year and last year but yes I
think that might have been in Bucharest
and just tell our viewers a bit about
this current position Queen's on ba
who's who who does that favor that
Black's Queen has been well the queen is
on B8 but is most likely coming back to
C7 so we're going to see this sequence
of you play whatever move you play as
white and my next move is almost
automatic E3 is A6 right yeah
yes on the board sorry on your board yes
yes I made this move Bishop to E3 which
probably will come on the board as well
right I can start with Bishop to E7 but
I can also just go A6 and ask the
question where are you going to go with
the Knight probably come back to the
center and then at some point Maybe not
immediately but I have to do something
about the pressure on the Knight on C6
and most likely I'm going to cover that
with the move Queen to C7 so we've seen
this idea Queen C7 you go Knight B5 I
hide my queen to B8 then I will play A6
and get my queen back to C7 in order to
uh be able to go B5 and continue my
attack and expansion on the queen side
so it's a very very typical structure of
the Sicilian and surely we're going to
see a fiery middle game in this one as
well thank you for that
something very very rare in our
experience of
calling these national championships
um
is something very strange out of the
opening because a lot of these top
players come with their preparation and
their preparation is extremely deep
sometimes 20 moves sometimes more I'm
looking at the game between Hans Neiman
and Ray Robson and Hans made
a London system move with Bishop F Ford
now if you go back one move
exactly in this position Bishop F4 is
completely completely standard
in conjunction with c2c4 this is
actually a very rare bird the difference
is is that often times with the pawn on
C4 the bishop check and be far too
disruptive like for example you could
imagine that after check maybe you would
like to play the move Bishop D2 having
already moved your you can imagine that
after Knight C3 Knight to E4 again you
would maybe like to have the bishop as a
defensive uh lead placed on D2 I once
played
well uh several times actually I played
Bishop G5 played this in the Phillips
and Drew tournament in in London and the
locals didn't know what to call it so
they called it
I beat Nigel short with it but it would
I didn't get an advantage out of the
opening at all I was looking actually to
do some trans positions with the move
Bishop uh to G
uh five Bishop F4 was hans's Choice
like that actually the Hans attack so
you know after D5 uh E2 E3 again E2 E3
you can again see why the bishop on F4
might not actually be the uh the best
placed I'm just putting some moves down
not necessarily good moves but you'll
understand why I'm doing this and just
kind of remind I'll go A3 and it's not
over but yeah the move Bishop B4 could
be disruptive but check this out C takes
D5 now Ray said well wait a minute I'm
probably
quite okay with E6 takes D5 I've opened
up my Bishop I'll I'm about to play
Bishop to
D6 but let me get ambitious yes let me
play Knight takes D5 with a with a Tempo
yes against the bishop what are you
going to do Han said well I'll drop back
with Bishop G3 and we have C5
E4 no this can't be really it is it's a
light F6 yeah yeah Knight D2 and what
Hans gives away
yeah yeah what's going on here Christian
I remember I looked at this uh in fact
for one of my students really a while
ago and we came to the conclusion that
it's maybe a one rapid game uh solution
but not more than that the reason that
uh Hans is playing it in a classical
game well it's quite uh befuddling
because I mean this one in general is
considered to be very good for black it
was a game and I believe it was a rapid
game as well between Magnus and Wesley
Magnus really likes to play this with
the white pieces this bishop to F4 and
take on D5 that wasn't the stem game
actually the stem game that
um I prepared this line for was between
mendonsa and uh lay I think this was uh
during one of those chess 24 rapid
tournaments uh between uh you
competition E4 Knight to F6 this is what
we have right now
in the position Knight to D2 and C takes
D4 in general is the move that I
recommend here you can also start with
the move Knight to C6 now I think the
game between Leon mendonsa and lei was
something along those lines like this
take on D4 E5 and now Knight to H5 now
what White's Improvement could
potentially be is that after taking on
D4 or maybe even Knight to C6 first
you go E5 first and now without the
Knight on F3 with the Knight on G1 black
doesn't have the move Knight to H5 so
that improves White's chances are
tremendously on the king side Knight to
D5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 this is the
type of position that we're going to see
most likely something along the lines of
Bishop to D3 Bishop to E7 you have to be
very careful as
um black at some point let's say the
move A3 and we will understand this move
in just a second castle now with the
move A3 and with the control the full
control of the B4 Square I will have
ideas of attacking the pawn on H7 maybe
with the move Queen to C2 and now you
have a big choice to make you can go
with the move G6 but most likely after
H4 and taking advantage of this hook
that you just created on G6 you will be
in trouble so I don't think you want to
see that on the board generally H6
should be considered as the main move
but then even this Pawn on H6 could
potentially become tender maybe H3
Bishop H2 G4 and G5 things of this
nature once again taking advantage of
the hook on H6 it's a very intriguing
middle game and I'm very curious to see
what Hans prepared uh yesterday because
he was saying that I'm going to look at
some Burly name games I don't believe so
I don't think he was looking at the
Berlin but he was definitely looking at
this one and
we actually asked him about his daily
routine check it out and I was just
wondering maybe Hans can share with us
how what is his routine looks like every
day like let's say when you are
preparing for your games what what else
you are doing here I'm not a few
stalkers I don't want to say
information on where am I being certain
times of the day so I will keep that to
myself right right okay but uh I have a
very
I I have a routine that I try to stick
to in the
uh
do you put glasses on when you go
outside you put like some hats
not really but the hair is is a hat
usually helps because the hair is
usually the giveaway right
um but you know let's just say that it's
hard for me to order food
do you feel that you're popular now I uh
ubereats isn't that great here
unfortunately
um but it's better than Miami yeah it's
no no Miami has a much better
um
um you know Miami had a more selective
but you know the Central West End is
just such a I can walk you know
everywhere in Miami I didn't leave my
hotel once so uh here it's walkable so I
prefer to go outside uh sometimes and
just you know it's a very nice
neighborhood I really like it but I will
not say which restaurants I go to every
day
just to be honest uh I already
um
yes that's that's that's that's all I
should say do you have a discount in
this place so why do you hide it let's
just say that um you know I I was making
an order and they knew my order and the
guy said to me you know this order
speaks for itself
so I'm not really enjoying the fact that
I cannot make a takeout order in privacy
but it's it's
um you know there are worse things that
you have to deal with on a daily basis
but uh again I'm here to play chess and
enjoy the great Cuisine of the Central
West End
the order speaks for itself exactly
actually this
this I remember I checked it out it was
like eight more than 80 000 people who
watched it watched it yes only on
YouTube channel and also you can imagine
how many people checked it there on
Twitter I called this
uh yesterday we actually had a kind of a
stunning experience thanks to uh
Grandmaster in Residence Alexander
shabala taking us or escorting Us
shopping I think we all had a great time
at the outlet
um here in
in St Louis and uh I'm pretty far away
from the club 20 miles and I had bought
some very becoming uh slacks by the way
very very nice and the lady asked
whether I was a part of their loyalty
award program and I said I wasn't and
she said well you could sign up for 15 I
said well I live in Amsterdam Amsterdam
she said well what brings you to St
Louis I said well the St Louis chess
club is hosting the U.S Championship she
goes oh lots of controversies in chess
yeah well like give me a 15 discount no
it didn't work but yes everybody
so what's going on here yes absolutely I
just wanted to pull up that position of
Christian because between uh Hans and
Rey should they get down this uh pathway
the pawn on E5
denying the night on F6 really led to a
wonderful attacks by Frank Marshall the
U.S champion from the 30s Queen C2 Queen
B1 attacking the pawn on H7
is very nice of course so if you play
Queen C2 and your opponent plays the
move H6 the move you immediately want to
play is Queen E4 getting in front of the
pawn of course so that you could force
that your opponent to play G6 or or F5
Frank Marshall had a different approach
he would play the move h2h4
really telegraphing that you go ahead
and you make a pass and there's a big
thump coming into the position thanks to
the pawn being on H4 so after a move
like H4 the opponent might play H6 and
then you go Queen E2 and you move it
before and you kind of get in front of
the bishop that way so sometimes that
move early Castles by black can walk
into a very nice attack Ray robson's
taking his time uh in this Pawn
sacrifice that we see on the board
Knight D2 and once again you mentioned
the stem game between Magnus and Atari
as well as Wesley and others how did
white do in these sacrifices did he win
well uh Wesley and tari was actually the
one uh the game uh related to the game
between Alshon and Fabiano okay so not
between this one actually you might be
right Magnus and Wesley look
I'm getting older good morning sir
just what I wanted to say that you you
should take some risks sometimes in
order to win a game right I mean let's
say maybe this variation is risky you
give away upon so early in the game but
on the other hand you try to play for
initiative even your mood can be better
you play both of those games
yes
yeah yeah he likes this Pawn sacrifice
and especially in Rapid encounters once
again those were rapid games not
classical games so Hans is following
magnus games right now yes oh yes it
learns from the best
um so one of the things what you were
just saying and I like to encourage what
you're saying sometimes you mix it up
you make these Pawn sacrifice says but I
want to say that Ray Robson has a
comfort zone as do we all we get in our
openings our defenses there are a lot of
positions we like to play and we can
play them quickly and easily Rey is a
thinker he loves to get into time
trouble regardless of the opening
somehow he always whether the position
is chaotic or quiet he's getting in the
opening so giving him something to Stew
on very very early I would say that
regardless of the outcome Hans is is
achieved what he wants which is to get
ray thinking early Around the Horn what
has caught your attention uh
uh Christian I was looking at uh this
game between the leader in the ladies
section Jennifer you and Alice Lee the
youngest competitor in both
championships only 12 years of age and
Alice Lee decided to go with the slav
defense and we have this very typical
variation with the move night wage for
early on hunting this light Square
bishop and uh Bishop to E4 was played F3
Bishop to G6 Queen to B3 Queen to C7 we
don't want to see Queen to B6 on the
board most likely because that's going
to invite an end game in which in
general uh only white can be better
because white will have more space but
also white will have the bishoper after
Knight X G6 this bishop is not running
anywhere I'm going to capture it at the
right moment and that's the thing about
the position I don't have to hurry with
uh playing the move Knight takes G6 I
can just leave this whole tension
between the Knight and the bishop for as
long as possible and that's going to be
quite uncomfortable in fact for black so
she decided to go Queen to C7 not only
that we're not exchanging the Queens not
inviting the end game but also we're
trying to take advantage and get some
compensation for what will be the two
Bishops that white will have because
after Knight takes G6 H takes G6 at
least you have some attack a brewing on
the king side given the fact that the
queen on C7 and The Rook on h8 are
combining nicely to attack and put
pressure on the pawn on H2 this is still
plenty of theory left and this position
she did not play that move after Queen
to C7 should not take on D6 she played
the move Bishop to D2 and let's see what
we have Bishop to E7 G3 defending the
Knight now you have to start looking at
ideas of Knight to E4 for black that's
why she played the move Bishop to E7 and
that's why white decided to defend this
Knight on H4 so for example if you play
a move such as Bishop to E2 you might
run into ideas of Knight to E4 Knight
ages a CSV Knight takes G6 Knight takes
D2 and now I'm attacking the queen you
take back I take back on G6 but this is
going to actually be favorable for black
so you don't want to see that on the
board G3 makes a lot of sense by the way
still in theory there has been uh 365
Games in this position take on C4 Bishop
takes C4 A6 this is what we currently
have on the board with this last move A6
obviously black is getting ready to play
the very uh nice sequence of moves B5
you drop the bishop back to D3 or E2 and
then I'm going to immediately follow it
up with the move C5 so she's definitely
putting some pressure now what Jennifer
can do to get ready for that sequence is
to meet the move A6 with the very
typical move A4 in the position waiting
for you to play the move B5 B5
unfortunately right now with the a file
opening up and the tension between the
Rooks on A1 and A8 is not possible so
you have to get ready for that you have
to go Castle then play the move Knight
bd7 defend the Rook on A8 with the Rook
on f8 and then only after that you can
play the move B5 still a very tense
middle game in uh this one it seems like
Alice Lee is still within her
theoretical knowledge perhaps she's she
hasn't thought for a very long time only
three minutes up to this point and
Jennifer down to her last one hour and
13 minutes so she's been thinking for a
little bit in this one
thank you for that Christian I'm
Anastasia I've never
surprised by the rich Pathways that can
occur in the Catalan I've seen open
catalans clothes cattle lands all kinds
of different approaches by both sides
and in the game between Alexander or
Alexander Linderman and Sam Shanklin we
have a Catalan so
we imagine the following situation
you're black and you're going to be
facing at your local chess club a player
who plays the Catalan as white so you
want to ask you know a top top
world-class Grand Master what's a good
system to play against the Catalan and
you know or Sam Shanklin knows before
the rest day that he's going to play
Lindeman he's going to play Catalan so
this is perfect yes so we say Okay
Grandmaster what is the best way
to handle the Cattlemen Sam Shanklin
says well let me show you first of all
you play Bishop P4 check Bishop D2 and
then you drop back with the bishop by
putting the bishop on D2 we're making
the argument that the bishop is actually
worse placed on D2 than on C1 because
maybe the pawn on D4 is a little
unprotected and maybe you're not going
to be into Shadow very good everybody
plays all the standard moves and after
the move C6 you're threatening to
capture the pawn so we defended Queen C2
and black weights well now we understand
the bishop on D2 isn't on its best
Square so it has let's move
five
okay fine we'll put our Rook on D1
Everybody Plays it H6
we don't understand what you're doing
we'll occupy the center Queen B6
Bishop back to E3 okay Queen A6 and it's
sort of like blood pressure magically
transports his Queen to the queen side
and you as you just said you put
pressure on C4 but also you're prepping
a potential B7 B5 as well as Knight
takes E4 D takes E4 Knight G4 and it it
just that the Catalan
despite the tens of thousands of games
the fact that players such as Anatoly
karapov carry Kasparov can play the
cannon Vladimir crime
that they're making good careers on the
white side of the Catalan we still see
these rich ideas Queen A6 uh according
to my table base it's in there it's a
known position but I'm just not familiar
with this and I just think that Sam
Shanklin has gone into the dusty parts
of the archive actually speaking about
preparation of Sam Shanklin that just uh
was I checked Facebook he had the post
he published a couple of photos of his
preparation uh and shaved and shaved
photo so I think he's really what's
preparing
very very hard and for those of you who
purchased uh those chessable courses
different person yes
you you know just how thorough he is and
and and what a student in the game very
very very diligent in his opening
preparation we'll see how this one pans
out and uh back to you uh Christian and
the game of our tournament leader Fabi
yes uh there's been a few moves since we
last saw this one and they're actually
following the path that we were
recommending just this dance between
ideas black just simply does not want to
play this move Knight to F6 and allow
the sequence Knight ac6 B takes C6 and
then E5 Fabiano Carona believes that
leads to a worse position and for good
reason and this is exactly what we've
seen from elshon as well Bishop to G3
Bishop to E7 waiting to commit to this
uh Knight to F6 move Bishop to E2 not
Queen to D2 because that will allow
Knight takes D4 E5 and then Knight to F6
and and we've seen that that usually is
quite well quite a good position for
black and Bishop to D7 was played by
Fabiano E5 was one of the main lines but
already this position is quite obscure
it hasn't been played as many times
Bishop to D7 is on the board and finally
you have to do something you have to
make a decision you don't have any
improving moves anymore you either go
Castle but that's very committal because
you commit uh to the king side for your
King's placement or you can go with the
aggressive Queen to D2 Queen to D2 I
think is going to be probably the choice
of elshon and we're going to follow that
up with castle and now with the bishop
on D7 there's a slight difference
because this Pawn on D6 is going to have
some difficulties staying on the board
without potentially playing the movie E5
and once you play the movie five I get
this D5 Square as white so I'm very
happy for uh that outcome so Queen to D2
what I'm seeing right now is some early
pressure from elshon moradia body in
this game between himself and the leader
Fabiano caruana and let's take a look at
what's happening in this Hans versus Ray
because a couple of moves have been
played as well E4 Knight to F6 Knight to
D2 and Knight to C6
so Ray thought for a little bit at this
point and he envisioned the type of
positions that we were discussing but
there's a big difference and that is
there's no Pawn on D4 so he played the
move Knight to C6 now you have to take
because if you don't take I'm going to
take back uh I'm going to take on D4 and
that's going to give me actually an
extra pawn and no compensation for white
so you don't want to see that take on C5
Bishop takes C5 E5 this is the position
we currently have on the board I'm not
particularly sure what he's thinking
about 95 seems like an automatic to me
just put the knight in the center and
take it from there and now this is going
to most likely lead to a very similar
position to what we had in our analysis
but without the pawn on D4 and that's
very important because not only that
whenever I move my knight I'm going to
have some pressure on the D file but
also I have ideas such as Knight to D4
Knight to D4 exchange some pieces in the
position make sure that you're not going
to Checkmate me on the king side because
that's White's plan you took some risks
from a strategical point of view as why
you play E4 E5 a bit overextended also
this bishop is just like eyeing uh its
own Pawn so there are some strategical
flaws in your opening Choice
nevertheless you do have an attack
Brewing on the king side all sorts of
like great gifts as you were pointing
out Yasser Bishop takes H7 Knight to G5
and all these check mailing threats so
black has to be careful and uh black
it's main strategy most likely has to be
related uh to exchanging pieces and this
is I think what Rey is envisioning in
this one and by the way after oh he's
still thinking after E5 wow big Choice
it seems like at least uh to his eyes
Knight to D5 and maybe Knight to D7
for me I'm with you I don't see the
choice Knight D5 would have been played
by Yours Truly some time ago Knight to
D7 I don't quite see why the Knight is
actually even better on D7 versus on D5
D7 it looks like it's in the way it's in
the way typical like from Switzerland
with this lines with Z5 Sicilian
um then it comes Knight go always goes
to D5 right I'd like to turn our
attention to the game between Wesley saw
our defending champion and linear
Dominguez for just a moment because I I
was an English player 1c4 uh rather
exclusively uh through much of my career
and one of my favorites was when my
opponent played the symmetrical C5 yes
C5 and I've gone to Yugoslavia and I was
the guest of Looper laboyevich and he
took me all over Belgrade well I had won
quite a lot of Yugoslavia in Dinars that
were unchangeable but I thought I was
going to be coming back to Yugoslavia a
lot I needed to open up a bank account
like this murder manka account anyway
they were happy to take my money yes but
they needed a key I had to give a code
yes so uh I wrote down C4 C5 yes G3 G6
Bishop G2 Bishop G7 Knight C3 Knight C6
A3
and lubo said we should stop right there
let's let's not go any further our bank
teller we don't want to give the novelty
to the banks because the bank teller was
actually a chess player as well and was
very interested in how the variations
continued well Lanier did not copy I had
a lot of games uh Sammy rashevsky and
many others with a7a6 Rook B1 Rook B8 uh
B4 and so forth and so on we had I
blazed a trail in in this line of the
symmetrical anyway
[Music]
the code the secret the secret code
actually quite often they use this one
right absolutely I mean who else will
know their novels he's a knight F3
Bishop B7 and you might recall that uh a
game between Sophie and Jennifer earlier
in the tournament you get it those bod
vinic Triangle Pawn
situations where white has this Pawn on
C4 and this Pawn on e4 puts the pawn on
D3 and I always thought of this as the
bod vinic Pawn triangle because Bob
vinnick had so many uh really masterful
games where there was this fight for D4
and D5 D7 D6 D3 and we've caught up with
the players uh still a very even game
but I've always liked these positions
for white why because I tend to think
that after Bishop G2 F4 I've got a
little bit more space on the king side
that I can deal with and it's really not
that easy for black to get in the move
D5 so black will oftentimes only be
reacting instead of developing a kind of
initiative we'll keep an eye on a Wesley
and it's actually thinking his choice
his opening choice is kind of
interesting probably he didn't want to
play the c45
he needs to win the game actually also
in order to try to fight for uh yes
exactly so I think that was a great good
choice you're right I remember Wesley
coming to Studio rather disappointed is
white he played one E4 his opponent
played E5 the Russian defense and he
came up with something very very lame
with like a bishop D3 and the game was a
quick
and Wesley kind of turns to our audience
and says please if you've got some
antidote for this Russian defense let me
know how to get an advantage because and
the C4 in English what he's playing
against Lanier he's got a game yes and
he doesn't play against teenager which
also helps yeah he doesn't play against
teenagers
[Applause]
very very nice to see you across the
board and by the way this is always a
good time to get in the early uh please
uh big shout out Welcome to our audience
thank you so much for joining us tell
your friends where you're hanging out
and at the same time join the discussion
put us to the test if you will ask the
commentators right yes ask the questions
I mean we're ready to answer all your
questions me yaser Christian we're here
for you right and to do that you just
need to follow our social media accounts
and especially Twitter accounts and
Foods Cheers club you can see it on the
screen and you use the hashtag
usgschamps in order to get through and
ask your questions and who is monitoring
all of the queries who we have a
journalist Vanessa West she's currently
taking care of our social media doing
great job she also writes really nice
Recaps after each round you can find
them on U.S chess website yes wonderful
wonderful and back over to you Christian
while I'm looking at this game between
Levon aronian and Darius zverge and is
very reminiscent of this game I think in
between ashrita with the white pieces
and Alice Lee early on in the tournament
when ashrita uh Uncorked this attack
this very early on devastating attack on
the king side H3 G4 G5 H4 yes and she
put a lot of pressure on her opponent in
that one actually she was winning with
this tactical Bishop takes H7 at one
point but this is what we have right now
Castle Rook to C1 so what black is
trying to do with his development up to
this point E6 C6 reinforced at the
support of uh the D5 pawn and at some
point at the right moment I need to
climb it very very well I will play the
move E5 and I'm going to try to put a
lot of pressure in the center E5
followed by Rook 2 E8 I'm going to have
all these ideas of D4 and opening up at
the position as such so how should white
develop his initiative in this position
and it seems like levon's response was
probably I'm going to go for G4 G5 and
try to kill you in this position and
this is exactly what's happening H3 is
on the board this is a novelty and it
seems like this is one of those moments
in which a very classical principles
apply very well what is white trying to
do white is trying to attack me on the
side on one of the flanks how should I
respond to that well with a counter
attack in the center so it seems like
the best move right now in the position
is to go E5 if you continue with your
Pawn avalanche on the king side G4
that's too fast you're going too fast
you're overextended and right now after
D4 you're actually in big trouble
Black Goes D4 you cannot take well you
can but after I take the e-file opens up
and after Knight takes D4 Rook to E8
let's say Bishop to E2 I'm going to have
incredible uh compensation for the pawn
not only that but I'm threatening this
move Knight to D3 right now you have to
be very careful for example if you go
something like B4 boom Knight takes D3
sayonara it's time to sign the score
sheets so you have to be very careful do
you want to Castle most likely not
because you just play the H3 followed by
G4 I'm going to break that structure
immediately with a move such as H5 it's
not looking good for white so this Pawn
sacrifice with E5 and once again it's
very classical right we've been taught
as young kids whenever your opponent is
attacking you on the side counter attack
in the center try to open the position
towards your opponent's king and this is
exactly what Darius is probably
pondering at this specific moment thank
you
immediately instead of slow H3
seconds
before it's possible here wow wow wow I
don't want to lose time you know for
this kind of Moves Like history right
why prepare an attack
simply go for it but maybe it's too much
yes I want to say that a lot I think it
was a Lexi Sheriff he was he was having
these positions where his opponent would
be playing E4 E5 and he was using G4
attacks he was his opponent was playing
uh semi-slav positions he was playing G4
attack so it was like the universal
Panacea whatever your his opponent did
somehow G4 was was part and parcel of uh
it's a fashion and everybody plays G4 in
every position right these days so if we
go back to this position on Assassin if
he said to me me you know what I want to
do I woke up this morning I want to
attack I want to play the move G4
regardless of what my opponent would do
I would applaud It In This Moment the
reason why Upon A G7 is not defended so
you could take Rook G1 you could take
but this Rook will eventually end up on
let's let's just put some moves down so
this is upon sacrifice oops excuse me
that you might really uh
except with Glee yes your queen is going
to go to H5 your Bishop is going to go
to B2 and I like it The Rook is on G7
in the game position however
yeah here the move G4 Knight takes G4
you know you can speculate that look you
know I've got the bishop on B2 I've Got
The Rook on G1 I'm really you know got
this yeah I got this great geometry I'm
going to kill you well it's going to
trust me
I may not believe you exactly G7 G6 I'll
shut down the G file and I'll deal with
this bishop Maybe by Queen E7 and Bishop
A3 remember
remember in the opening what are your
three goals as a player to develop your
pieces correct effectively yes that's
important exactly put your Kink into the
safe place
you you got your fair share of the
center and both players are fighting for
the center and then you have a safe
place for your king when you've got the
Rook already on C1
uh
uh you're and you're playing for G4 your
safe place
I'm not 100 sure that will be true
especially in those variations that
Christian was just telling us E5 and you
know open up the center when the king's
in the center not so cool not so cool I
wanted to take our uh attention to the
game of a Wonder
and Christopher you for just a second
because I think at a certain moment
we've been talking about this move G4
and I wanted to say look I mean you
don't need to do it in a lemons game
we have more games here we go here we go
I wonder Leah after the movie Bishop uh
E2 I wonder who by the way I think is
enjoying back-to-back whites as he just
beat levana said uh you know if I were
to win today just imagine how cool that
would be that would mean I'm tied for
first with Bobby yes let me play G4 and
go for it well if Bobby doesn't win
exactly yeah well I mean you know step
by step right uh H7 H6 and the move uh
G4 to my eyes at least is when you see
this move H6 you're kind of happy there
because you've got this hook that means
whenever Black's King goes to the king
side you've got G5 now I'm not sure I
would play H4 and fact I'd very much
like to get my king out of Dodge with
Queen D2
I wonder well pardon me after age six no
we don't have it yes we do have a move
uh we have the move Knight D4 and I
found that move surprising because in my
mind I'm waiting for A6
as soon as you play the move A7 A6 I'm
gonna Retreat my night clear but I want
you to commit your self to A6 so like I
might just just throwing out a a
different move for just a second G4 H6
it looks kind of funny to play the move
Rook G1 but I'm just throwing that out
there and as soon as you play A6 I'm
ready to jump back
uh I'm a little bit surprised by the
move oops excuse me can I do for you
Knight D4 voluntarily and Christopher
said well that was nice of you you
didn't make me play A6 let me see if I
can't save a Tempo by playing Bishop D7
and maybe I can play for B5 now without
Basics yeah yeah maybe now that my
Queen's on B8 so a very very cagey
intriguing Affair taking place between
these two youths
I like it very much and one game that we
haven't really uh taken a look at but uh
let's do it right now Sam sevion versus
uh has Joey Bray likes to say Jeffrey X
uh-huh Jeffrey X Jeffrey Zhang
these two players more or less I think
they're the same age uh have been we we
have to stop talking about them being
talented Junior yes they're already
seriously talented veterans
I want to say and they're following a
very theoretical dispute right up until
this moment a2a3 I guess this is the
latest and greatest going on in this uh
line of play as Sam has re has won back
his Pawn it's not a Berlin
that King in the center makes a strange
impression as does whites so white wants
to play castles of course it's not
really possible it's not Fisher those
darn fide rules and stopping us from
castling along when we need it well well
please I have uh how did we call that uh
Christian chaos
where you can fly things around
not once per game at least you don't
have a duck
I'm sorry from doctors that was a lot of
fun sorry for those of you missed it uh
the the day before the free the night
before the free day a big shout out to
our friend Eric Rosen yes a streamer
extraordinaire and photographer
extraordinary he was hosting a party and
Katya uh
yes challenged me to a variant of Chess
called duck chess where the duck acts as
a bridge as a brick pardon me and
prevent you from making moves long story
short I got the whole party on my side
at the table
everything was and lots of hands were
helping me but we couldn't beat her no
no she is very strong she's very strong
she took us down in ducky chest like a
chest and you got one dog exactly that
was the good news I got a duck out of
the deal
did you throw in some help on the ducky
chest oh yeah yeah yes yeah Krista was
also there I think I was just trying to
analyze the position yeah it was going
above my head I mean it's so difficult
so much more difficult than just it's
definitely right very cool variant I
have to say I think it's going to get
developed quite nicely and it's also
good for Content you see these beautiful
toxic landing on the board that
definitely looks nice on a camera so I
was actually looking at the ladies
section please guys because I think we
haven't looked at them in a while and I
was looking at this game between Anna
zatonski and gulrook peginto Nova
because they've played this line that
we've seen between Sam Shanklin
Sam came up with this brilliant idea
Bishop to G5 Bishop to A6 and queen to
C1 yes that was the novelty right Queen
to A4 was one of the main lines Queen to
C2 and queen to C1 was the big big
novelty but in this one Anna zatoski
decided to go with an early G3 so
already committing to developing the
bishop on G2 not allowing all those type
of complications after ideas of E4 as we
were seeing Sam uh pointing to us and
Bishop to A6 was played they're still
following one of the main lines of this
variation what surprises me a lot is
that Anna right now is down to her last
51 minutes so she's been thinking for a
very long time to get to this position
which has been played before yeah
aronian versus topalov we've seen some
games from uh that's 2008 so perhaps one
of the sides I'm not particularly sure
which one abandoned this particular line
with G3 and queen to C2 and perhaps for
a good reason because I'm looking at the
position and obviously the most natural
move is to go Castle right but how are
you going to respond after move Rook to
C8 I'm putting a lot of pressure on the
C file I already have this big threat of
taking on D4 you cannot go and Hunt my
Bishop with Queen to A4 because the pawn
on E2 is hanging so you have to be
careful about that now that you castled
so how are you going to continue this
position of the Rook to C8 you probably
will take on C5 but then I can just
simply take with them I might maybe even
take with the Rook on C5 you have to
drop back to d8 Rook to D5 at least I
have it seems like some sort of an
equality right because I don't think you
want to go uh Bishop to D2 uh you're
going to have to suffer after Knight to
C5 Knight comes to E4 I'm taking
advantage of this pin you have to hide
and get out of Dodge but it's not
looking good for a while right so you
have to be very careful and this is what
she's doing right now she's trying to
find a way to get out of trouble she
might be in some early trouble in this
game between herself and gulrook begin
to hear jonova funny enough the position
that's on your board is an exact
position that I was analyzing oh my gosh
for candidates tournament oh my goodness
yes way back in the day way back in the
day I wonder what chess engines think of
my ideas now I wanted to play B4 yeah as
white in this position because the
bishop is on G2 and I really want you to
take on D4 so I can go Knight to C6 and
then in a very nice way and my idea was
that if they played Rook C8 after before
after B4 then I actually wanted to go
with this queen to not A4 but Queen to
B2 and I was thinking that you know I'm
just gonna have the two Bishops uh I
wanted to see the move C4 don't ask me
why so I
so I could be like uh A4 and uh I was
trying to artificially isolate the C
pawn and like exactly this position uh
let's say queen to C2 and my ideas were
to play B5 and Bishop A3 again I I
haven't seen it since 20 30 years ago
you should be glad you didn't play it
yeah exactly well nobody gave me the
chance it says you're
oh my God I'm glad the computers weren't
around I was like I I was creative
no but it's very interesting I have to
give it to you before he's a very very
good move and probably actually the best
move objectively the problem is that
after Rook to C8 which is very natural
uh you do have to go Queen to A4 now we
see why you didn't commit to Castle yet
right there's no more Bishop takes uh E2
and by the way this goes into a
completely crazy line after uh before
you take and then I go Bishop to D5 in
fact and I'm playing for initiative in
the position but I have to say B4 is
putting a lot of questions uh for black
is posing a lot of questions for black
so I like this idea of B4 let's wait and
see whether Anna is going to be going
for it because you haven't castled yet
you haven't finished your development
and your opponent is one move away of
creating from creating a lot of of big
threats with Rook to C8 so you have to
be brave in order to play this move B4
how many months or like weeks did you
analyze this move uh before yes sir well
weeks would probably be over doing it
but definitely a few days you did look
at it yeah yeah yeah I mean it was a the
Catalan has always been around it kind
of goes in and out of fashion but it's
been around for 70 80 years and uh in
those days we had Catalan players I was
one I I liked it yes sir I wasn't and
you were analyzing on your own or you
had someone to analyze together I mean
it's not that easy to convince yourself
no it it was very very difficult and
that's one of the things I really like
about today's modern engines was because
you have an opponent you have somebody
who you can cross swords with and and I
like these these uh comments of vashir
Anand that I had asked him how he comes
up with his opening ideas he says well I
really don't I have this idea I put it
into deep Fritz
overnight yes I go to sleep I come back
and the engine says good
good idea it is a bad idea or you can't
play and it is it's really uh that that
uh cut and dry it was never cut and dry
we were always looking for the truth of
the positions and very very often we
would prepare it ourselves and we were
still doubtful but then we would
convince ourselves well we I have more
experience than my opponent so I should
play it and be able to get away with it
I'd like to turn our attention to the
game of Hans Neiman for just a second
and Ray Robson if you look at the clocks
you see a very very significant
difference in time roughly speaking one
hour 23 minutes for Hans which means
he's used seven minutes of his starting
time and Rey already underneath an hour
even worse underneath 50 minutes on the
clock let's pick up what has happened
because in my opinion Hans is going to
be very pleased about the outcome of the
opening after the move a2a3 uh B7 B6
for obvious reasons with the bishop you
want to put the bishop on D3 but it
could be a Target like this Knight on D5
would move with a discovered attack
against the bishop so you start with the
move Knight E4 now if Rey obliges
obliges by just dropping back with the
bishop for just a moment we'll play
Bishop E4
pardon me yes apologies uh if we imagine
there was a black pond on D4 that would
just have been the position that we kind
of analyzed there's no Pawn on D4 so
Hans hasn't sacrificed anything and
still has good position exactly thanks
to thanks to this Pawn on E5 which he's
leveraging into control of the F6 as
well as the D6 I can make the next moves
very easily for White Queen E2 castles
bring my Rooks to the D file and maybe
one day I could just land on the Square
D6 and be happy in the meanwhile Rey is
going to play Bishop B7 Rook to C8 but
you start thinking well okay where
should I be attacking should I be
attacking on the king side why am I
going to play F5 probably then you can
have an and then the six will be recall
forever right yes but it seems like yes
if you if you go in this direction just
as you're saying you just saddled
yourself with a permanent weakness so I
do feel that Hans is again won the
opening battle and he certainly won it
on the chess clock as well so things are
looking good for Hans as far I believe
Rey is also one of those players with
five consecutive draws yes it looks like
this I don't remember him winning yeah
so I think Hans also is at 50 but he got
there with a win and a loss and back
over to you uh Christian this game
between el Shan Muradi abadi and Fabian
karawana has actually uh changed quite a
lot let's see what happened Bishop to D7
was played and we were recommending
ideas of Queen to D2 followed by Castle
elshon decided to take this Knight out
of the way out of Dodge and take
advantage of your last move Bishop to D7
put pressure immediate pressure on D6 so
you have to find a way to defend against
that Queen to C7 seems to be the main
line but E6 also E5 excuse me makes a
lot of sense as well never ever less
once you play A5 you have to deal with
ideas and consequences of me placing a
knight on D5 and perhaps this would have
been the right decision by white he
decided to go in a completely different
Direction with this move Bishop to G4
trying to exchange take advantage of the
fact that the Knight is not yet on F6 so
I have the opportunity to exchange the
light Square bishop and after that I'm
going to be able to take advantage of
the pawn of the square D5 much more
comfortably now the problem with this is
that after Bishop takes G4 Queen takes
G4 sure you are threatening to take on
G7 but check this move out H5 attacking
the queen do you want to take on G7
Mansion upon perhaps no no no because
after the move H5 there's no more Queen
G4 back you're not coming back home and
The Queen Is Lost you can resign at that
point and you have only one move at this
point because if you go Queen F4 Queen
E2 Queen F5 Queen anywhere except the
the move that was played in the game
Queen to H3 I'm going to go H4 and you
lose a piece right
so he played them of Queen to H3 this is
what we have right now in the position
but it's somewhat striking that you're
allowing black so much counter play and
so much speed and momentum in the
position I see H4 coming you have to
play moves such as F3 to try to get this
bishop back into play via F2 but then
once again the queen on H3 is going to
be a little bit uh off play as well so
I'm not liking this decision by elshon
muradiabadi uh he is quite confident
after this bishop to G4 he hasn't spent
as much time Fabiano down to his last 55
minutes or a little bit behind his
opponent on the clock but I have to say
the last sequence of moves I think
favors the Fabiano caruana the current
leader of the tournament
I love these kinds of battles these
strategic battles no question you've got
this little initiative the bishop on G3
looks saddened there but if I could just
say I like the fact I have D5 after
um Queen H3 if you do play H4 I will
play F3 the bishop will drop back I have
no real weaknesses obviously my queen
might be safer on E2 rather than H3 but
long term
I can see a not too distant Universe
where the Knight Will land on D5 and
elshon might say hey I've outplayed
fobby in the opening how will foul be
how should Fabi react in this moment so
I think um everything is contingent to
you managing to play long castle that's
why okay if you manage to go long castle
and put some pressure on the D file I
think you will be successful in what you
just described right but let's take a
look so H4 so concrete right yes
concrete moves now I go Bishop G5 oh no
more castle that crosses me up yeah once
you go short Castle then my expansion on
the king side makes some sense right
because exactly potentially I have ways
to soften you up even with G5 G4 at the
right moment and open you up and the
king is going to be exposed so not so
easy
of course the Battle of course of course
of course and uh that's why I will play
this move Bishop to G5 but still very
very complex position I have to say and
both sides I mean they have to be
extremely precise in their plan
execution in this one wonderful thank
you Christian and as we prepare for
break Anastasia tell us about our
friends at Q Boutique and what's today's
specials uh Joshua was wondering if you
are collecting magnets because this is
yes yes I am yes I am good I'm a big
chess set collector because it's time to
buy one yes a refrigerator Magnus
something maybe oh uh no I'm not
collecting those but maybe I should tell
everybody yes because actually we have
very good one and you can find it in the
world just Hall of Fame it's actually
devoted to 1972 Fisher's passkey match
so you can collect souvenirs from the
Hall of Fame
newest exhibition the match its region
and influence you remember the topic 19
1972 Fisher's past image this is a two
inch three inch fridge magnet features
the images of Bobby Fisher and the Boris
mask and Boris bosky so you can find
them also in cubic St Louis shop online
wonderful it was time to get one right
yeah they look very very attractive
indeed I'm running
shopping is good yes
was he on the other side of the bridge
thank you
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at stlouischessclub.org
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in St Louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from laumeyer Sculpture Park and the
city garden to the stunning Cathedral
Basilica one of the largest Mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing St Louis is on
display all year long ooh now that's an
exhibit
St Lou is always exploring
foreign
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
[Music]
the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
out
the sound of personalized Healthcare
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
six of us championships we are indeed
underway and some exciting games and I'm
finding myself drawn to those games that
have some very nice strategic approaches
I've always loved these
battles of ideas and I'm seeing it in
the game between Alexander Lindemann and
Sam Shanklin that was the Catalan I had
spoke about with this
maneuver bringing the queen to A6 to put
pressure on the C4 Square the way that
tension got resolved is Alex captured on
D7 put the pawn on C5 and said
I've got you your Bishop on D7 is
trapped behind your own wall of Pawns
and Sam said I understand that let me
play the move Bishop to E8
prepping Knight D7 and E5 and maybe even
on a good day this bishop will emerge on
the king side well Alex said let me
cross up your plans if you put your
knight on D7 too early I may end up
playing Bishop to E6 and forcing you to
give me a pass Pawn on the D6 Square
asset or reliability well the only time
will tell us questions Christian will
let us know Bishop F4 intriguing game
but the game that really caught my
attention was the one between a Wonder
uh Liang and Christopher you what we
might call the four pawns attack
on the king side poor Farms attack on
the inside E4 F4 G4 H4 is white over
committed himself the last moves were B5
Knight to D1 and before white plays
Knight F2 and consolidates and plays for
the move she G5 the question that we
have to ask and answers how are we going
to meet E6 E5 Anastasia just reminding
us that we've taken some responsibility
by moving all the pawns up the board
um so and I wasn't sure
you know outbreaks are too short it's
like you you take a deep breath and it's
like uh return to Studio yes exactly
like my goodness uh Christian Jump Right
In uh
sometimes during the breaks I hear one
more story from you guys here actually
it's just one story and again
we're back in studio
uh what's going on uh Christian in this
game because e6e5 is oh The Rook is on
G1 yes I'm getting flashbacks of I
thought the Rook was on H1 so yeah yeah
that's the problem that's a big problem
uh remember the game between Tokyo
Genova and Irina Crush I'm getting
flashbacks from that game uh and I spoke
with beg him after that game she wasn't
happy and I wasn't happy either because
she was playing such disconnected chess
and this seems to be the case in this
one as well because sure you play G4 H
for Rook to G1 but as you were
mentioning Yasser you still haven't
Castle you are still a couple of moves
away from hiding the King on C1 and
castling finishing your development so
let's try to take advantage of that and
immediately put pressure on your
position with this move E5 The Rook on
G1 we understand it defends uh the pawn
on G4 and that's why he played the move
Rook to G1 so that whenever you go E5
there's no Knight hd4 sighting the prop
problem is that you have another
weakness in the position so let's say
you take take Queen to D3 you have to
stay connected with this Pawn on e4
otherwise Knight takes E4 come on the
board right I can do that and I can
finish my uh development and I can bring
more pieces into the attack with tempo
as black Bishop to C6 I'm attacking the
pawn on e4 Knight to F2 Queen to B7 I'm
attacking the pawn on e4 if you go
Bishop to F3 you're already lost Rook to
d8 you're not castleing anytime soon
your queen is in a tremendous uh is
under tremendous pressure on D3 you want
to go to E2 sure but now I'm just
picking up oops your Pawn you want to go
to C4 sure but I mean look at your King
right all I have to do is go A5 A4 B3
and give you a check on B4 right and the
game is over right so you have to be
very careful right now and in fact this
position is just completely lost for
white so wow lost completely completely
lost that position is already completely
lost you have to do other things in fact
after E5 take take let's say queen to D3
Bishop C6 Knight to F to Queen to B7
what you have to do is give up the pawn
with the movement yes castling but I
mean a pawn is a pawn I'm gonna take
that prove the compensation yeah I'm
going to take it I understand you
probably do have some compensation as
white but I have my own attack on the C
file right you're not that close to
finishing your development Rook to C8
especially if you take on e4 and the
bishop lands on e4 you're going to have
to worry about Rook to C8 and if you
actually have to go into this end game
what happened there sure I mean we're
going to exchange the Queens but we're
going to exchange the Queens on my term
yes I'm not going to go King to f8 I'm
not going to lose the right to Castle
I'm going to go Queen to C6 and this uh
I mean the position speaks for itself
it just feels like black is better black
is a pawn up there's not that much
compensation it is going to be white who
has to prove that he has enough to
maintain equality which I don't think he
has in this particular case and by the
way the moves up to this point they flow
very naturally right you go E5 you go
Bishop C6 you go Queen to B7 so
Christopher you right now maybe in the
drive but wait he went the wrong he went
D5 he went D5 completely different
approach oh my goodness
that's yes
this supposedly is actually pretty bad
after G5 okay which is what G4 was all
about makes the most sense right right
yes and we get this position but
I mean this is such a thing this is
white any day such a better Improvement
right compared to what we have promote
the bones maybe I'm not sure
maybe maybe not immediately but yeah
it's okay because that pawn is King F1
and you're almost two moves away uh six
I have ideas of softening you up on the
light scores with Bishop B5 as well
Bishop F6 is good enough yeah
for sure I'm not sure like what's good
exactly that pawn is close attention yes
yes of course I mean if you take on G5
I'll take back with the F Pawn maybe
even with the uh H Pawn but if I take it
with the F Pawn then I still have the
agents running down the board right so
it's all about priorities right now and
it seems like priority number one is to
hide my king on C1 exactly the way I do
that is with Knight to F2
um I'm looking at the position and I
definitely see white in polar position
right now uh to take the advantage if he
finds this move G5 which to my eyes
makes a lot of sense absolutely no uh
big uh big Miss there by Christopher I
think the E5 would have brought
um our 15 year old an advantage turning
our attention to Hans uh versus Rey uh
Ray Robinson fans are just you know
because once again Rey really has gone
way down on the clock uh underneath 40
minutes now and his position really has
not improved when we left it we just saw
the move Knight E4 give me the two
Bishops uh and Ray said well I see that
the bishop is coming to D3 the queen is
coming to E2 I'll tell you what I want
to play Bishop A6 go ahead and take my
Bishop maybe my queen will come to B6
and I'll get some compensation for the
two Bishops in my split Pawns
Hans said I don't have to take your
Bishop in fact I really like loading up
on this file because there are pieces on
C6 in particular that could be weak
Knight D7 so hanza's opening is really
paid very very big dividends again on
the clock and in the position I do like
what is happening for uh White and
Christian we have a very special guest
from The World Chess Hall of Fame uh I
want to say a famous Musician musician
we are indeed with Brian Woods who is
the director uh the music director at
the World Chess Hall of Fame Brian first
of all welcome to the show tell us a bit
about what you do at the workshops Hall
of Fame sure thank you for having me
um I'm a concert pianist by by trade so
uh what I've trained at the Royal
Conservatory in Toronto I'm based here
in St Louis and so what I do personally
is I travel to the United States and I
performed solar recitals and I do solos
with orchestras so that's what I do but
but at the World Chess Hall of Fame what
I do is I lead the classical programming
at the witch off as we call it for World
chest Hall of Fame which off music
series so alongside my co- music
director Brian Owens who does the
non-classical programming we program two
concerts a month that you can come and
see here at the Royal Chess Hall of Fame
featuring musicians from all over the St
Louis area in all genres of music so on
the classical end which is what I do I
partner with the St Louis Symphony area
groups I myself perform on occasion and
we put on concerts
every month and so we get to hear from
Opera groups string quartets solo
pianists wind quintets all kinds of
ensembles of music that you can come and
enjoy at the World Chess Hall of Fame
speaking of you performing as well let's
take a look at one of your research
performances
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
tell us a bit about that night how are
the emotions that night well I couldn't
hear exactly what was in the clip but
I'm guessing it was Chopin that I was
playing from what I was looking at and
that was the debut of my concert
wanderings which is a concert that I've
been touring around the United States
and you can learn all more about this at
Brian woodspians.com which is where you
can learn about me as a performer but I
debuted this concert with rexinkfeld in
the audience who is this incredible
supporter of everything that happens
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame and
there was a lot of pressure that night
it was all new music for me I'd never
played this music before in public it
was the entirety of the Chopin for
balads which are some of the most
dramatic and challenging pieces in The
Pianist repertoire so a little bit of
pressure but it was it was an exciting
night and it was a an incredible event
and it's all on YouTube if you if you
want to watch it at the World Chess hall
of fames YouTube channel so all there
for you to see and you guys performed
the piece during the singfield Cup
Opening Ceremony as well tell us a bit
about that so Brian Owens came up to me
or approached me over email about a week
before the sink fold cup happened and he
said look we're planning this original
piece that was based on Bobby Fischer
and uh it I didn't really know what it
was it was he sort of handed me a piece
of music and I said I'm not sure how
this all fits in I showed up the day of
the opening ceremony we we met about two
hours before the ceremony started and it
was this very almost um hamilton-like
kind of presentation of a moment in
Bobby Fischer's life involving uh
hip-hop and piano playing and a band and
so we got to perform this for everyone
who was there for the opening ceremony
the single cup and it just could not
have been more exciting that kind of
live feel of putting something together
that was new you know I'm In classical
music I often put together things that
are very old so this was an exciting
thing for me to work on something that
was so new and so fresh it's felt like
you guys were playing together for a
lifetime you said you met two hours
before and you put that together that's
in impressive yeah that's nice of you to
say I mean we we really uh with
musicians at this level I think we're so
accustomed to putting together things
very quickly and very last minute so
that was the um the excitement about it
but I mean I say it was last minute he'd
been putting a lot of time and energy
into it I was just as I said sort of a
cog in the machine but it was a fun
night talk to me about the music series
uh can the public join absolutely and
and we actually have a concert coming
this week um the winter Opera St Louis
is coming on this Thursday night October
13th and that's at 7 p.m we have our
concerts with a an artist talk at 6 pm
and
um tickets are still available I
encourage folks to head to worldchess
hof.org and slash programming there's
that tab at the top of the screen that
you can check out all the things that we
have going on at the World Chess Hall of
Fame but that's a concert that's
happening this month just last month we
had the string quartet which is an
incredibly famous string quartet here in
St Louis that performed specifically for
us at the World Chess Hall of Fame so
there's so much going on and and tickets
are still available for concerts that
are happening this month so I would
encourage everyone to check it out Brian
thank you very much for joining us guys
any questions oh yes oh yeah
most definitely Brian one of uh the
secret Pleasures I have in life as a
chess Grandmaster is when I walk past a
chess Hustler and he says you know let's
play for ten dollars and I think to
myself death is walking by this this
great movie shine where in the movie
there's the piano bar scene he comes in
and he starts playing and it's just
absolutely brilliant have you ever
walked into a bar
everything's quiet sat down on the piano
and just wowed everybody into submission
silence and then magnificent Applause is
that something that happens for you uh
sometimes I would say I I will say in
the Rome airport one time I was coming
back from a performance there and there
was a piano in the in the airport in
Rome and I started playing some
Beethoven and and folks sort of gathered
and I suppose it was a similar situation
right
um I can't say I played I played the
Flight of the Bumblebee like he did in
that in that bar and shine but it was
definitely a similar experience and it's
always fun because you always run into
music lovers that you would not expect
out in public which is really what we do
as musicians it's for it's for others so
that's that's always a fun time
wonderful much much success in
everything you do here in Swain St Louis
and good luck on your career thank you
very much absolutely I was wondering
actually if you if you play some chess
uh but yeah
musician I know how's your Catalan folks
outside I said I I played I played some
with my brother when I was a kid but
it's been some time and I I'm afraid I'm
embarrassed myself it's time to learn
something
there's a lot in common between
musicians and chess that's fine
especially with just it just um you know
the strategy of it all and just the
mental focus that you have to have in a
performance in a chess match there's
there's so much overlapping and so we
like to say you know there's that same
kind of black and white Vibe with the
piano keys and the and the chessboard as
well and and it it works so well
together so you wouldn't imagine that
these two things would be you know uh
perfect Partners but it works out
incredibly well exactly
loves music and classical music as well
I don't know if you have visited
performances in the Hall of Fame but he
should be should definitely be the one
from players yeah we do a great we do
actually there's always a couple
Grandmasters who like to show up to a
lot of our a lot of our concerts I think
um you know oftentimes chess players or
music lovers and there's a lot of famous
composers that are all of our chess
players and so like I said there's just
so much overlap and it's such a delight
to see that all come together at the at
the World Chess Hall of Fame thank you
so much thank you Brian again good luck
and with the concert coming up
uh turning our attention back to the
game between our tournament leader
Fabiano uh black against elshon pretty
much as uh was prescribed by Christian
after the queen went back to H3 uh Fabi
recognized the absolutely huge
importance of not allowing black pardon
me not allowing white to Castle Queen
side so that the root would be on D1
menacing the pawn on D6 and the king
would be perfectly safe over here on the
B1 square and said Bishop G5 immediately
cutting off that opportunity white was
forced to Castle short which at the same
time put the king in somewhat a bit of a
trouble Zone but really the problem for
white is this queen if the queen were
anywhere E2 D3 doesn't matter
not on this unfortunate Square I like
White's position
just the Queen's position for the moment
moment like you imagine yourself well
how are you going to get it back you
would like to go H3 and queen G2 but H
G3 pardon me will always walk into an um
into a capture and blacks for Choice the
moment not so easy to get in the move
Knight D5 elshon's Knight on
um
I'd probably be tempted to play Knight
B3 to C1 to E2 but I'm doing it more as
a defensive reaction than an offensive
reaction I think Fabi actually has a
slight upper hand at the moment how to
take advantage of the fact that the
queen that white screen is so far away
normally you try to play on the side
where
um Queen cannot be placed right exactly
I don't know maybe something on the
queen side yeah well one of the things
that you could do as Black's position is
actually just kind of slow play it you
just like uh you you start to look
around and say well where how can I
improve uh the position uh as you said
should I play B7 B5 Rook to C8 bring my
Rook uh at a certain moment you don't
want to be playing with a queen out of
the game
um also although it's a long long way
away
you might want to be a little bit
mindful that oh excuse me I I did it the
wrong way I wanted to say imagine I
could put a knight on F4
okay yeah it would be nice yes
exactly Knight H5 will invite
the movie 95. so as black I start to
think well maybe I should play 97 with
the idea of bringing this Knight around
to the F4 Square then I can use the Rook
on uh H6 to go to G6 so I'm beginning to
see more opportunity I want to put it
like that for Fabi than I do for Alshon
elshon is probably thinking to himself
well again not a great night let me
recharge it maybe I should play A3 and
Rook D3 trying to double my Rooks you
start to think where are my active plans
and frankly let's say I play A3 and
let's just go like something like this
right I see myself
trying to stop you from like the four
right more than you know I wanted to
play Rook to D3 and Rook D1 so I see a
very intriguing game uh ahead for us in
this one turning it over to uh Christian
and Christian what card girl that is
definitely a very very intriguing game
the one that you guys were talking about
and that was the big problem white
doesn't really have a clear plan right
while black is having a lot of options
Knight d8 Knight to E6 Knight to F4 take
advantage of that Queen placement on H3
put some pressure on the C file Fabiano
still has a lot of ways to improve his
position elshon I'm not 100 sure about
that so Fabiano definitely very happy
with the outcome of the opening now
let's take a look at this game between a
wonder and Christopher what happened in
this one we left it off after the move a
D5 and he did not play the move G5 he
played the move Knight to F2 now it's
very easy to at the position and think
about what is my prior priority as white
first of all is to just get the king to
C1 how do I do that sure after Knight to
F2 that fails to uh be a very fluid plan
right we have two followed by Castle
this seems like the right solution now
G5 would have been the better option
take take or you can take only four
first and Rook to f8 and then Knight to
F2 you see this position and I was
trying to understand why he rejected
this idea and you see this move Knight
to D6 what is Knight D6 doing well not
only that is trying to look towards the
queen side and a potential attack
against the king that is going to Castle
there but also I'm looking at ideas of
Knight to F5 and almost trapping the
queen not only that but you also have to
worry about the bispawn E3 so you see
this position you calculate it and then
you think about ideas well how do I stop
the move Knight to F5 Bishop D3 if you
take on h65 Queen of Fate I don't know
what are you going to take with no
that's the question right if you take
with the queen after Knight and five you
just lose right if you take with the
pawn I have a feeling you still lose the
piece uh did you did we calculate
variation queen of Fate queen of Faith
here yes very nice very nice yeah I
don't know that's okay but I think it's
nice too yes you get the queen and then
I'll take your Rook on A1 and that seems
to be uh giving black a decisive
Advantage yeah it looks nice it looks
beautiful but it doesn't work absolutely
and he probably was looking at this type
of ideas and maybe saw the move Knight
to D6 and got scared right but after
Knight to D6 maybe bishop to D3 just
take away the F5 Square nevertheless
there's so many things to calculate in
the position Bishop to B5 it's all about
this F5 square right now I need to get
my knight to F5 with a very very
complicated position what he played was
Knight to F2 take only four and long
Castle this is what we have right now in
the game obviously white is ready to
take on uh E4 while he's ready to go D5
G5 as well Queen to B6 though it's a
very nice move in the position because
it forces almost the queen trade the
only way to get out of the queen trade
is to go Queen to D2 but that makes your
position more passive your queen on D4
was doing a tremendous job putting
pressure on G7 as well as E4 from D2 it
doesn't do any of that so I can just
simply drop back with a queen to C7 and
the position seems to be uh preferable
for black G5 Knight to D5 I like the way
black species are looking in this
instance so Queen to B6 big move right
now for Christopher possible in the
position and maybe you could even give
him the objective Advantage after Queen
to B6 let's see if he finds that it's
going to be an intriguing game moving
forward for sure
wonderful thank you for that Christian
going through some of the ladies games I
must say I'm seeing a lot of ambitious
play by The Players let's pick up the
action between our tournament leader
Jennifer Yu and her key matchup with
Alice Lee this is the position of the uh
at the time we're picking up the action
to remind our viewers we left it at the
moment after A7 A6 we saw that Alice
could be menacing B5 Knight D7 and C5
ideas Jennifer nipped
A4 Knight D7 A5 so basically she's
saying anytime you put try to play for
B5 I will make an ampissant after a
night
age five threatening to capture Jennifer
said well I'm very very happy to take
your Bishop captures and I really like
this move Knight E4 I think a lot of us
would have been happy to Castle and say
go ahead take my pond I'll take your
Pawn type of thing but this move Knight
E4 has a really nice and very ambitious
idea obviously I defend the pawn on G3
but on the other hand I also if the
night ever goes back to F6 you've always
got to be mindful Maybe not immediately
that the Knight comes to G5 and you
can't kick it away after Knight to E4
Alice has castled castled and we've
caught up to the players
Jennifer our tournament leader really
ambitious putting a Pawn on A5 ideas
like if you make something
you make a move like night to uh uh F6
Knight could come to uh a G5 Bishop
takes E6 all of these sacrificial ideas
and for Alice she has to be very careful
this bishop on D2 is uh I want to say
quiet but imagine in the position that
we have on the board white starts to
play moves like King B1 Bishop B4 and
suddenly D6 could become tender so I
imagine that Alice needs to make some
very careful well-considered decisions
here to match Jennifer's very ambitious
play G4 is actually a threat or Not Here
Knight F6 and 95 let's say your plan
H2 is protected once at least I'm not
sure the queen this queen will run but
just exactly on what you're saying as
why you're often thinking how do I
activate the bishop so if I can play G4
and Bishop G3
even at the cost of the spawn on A5 uh
the bishop on G3 will be really a very
very powerful Bishop another game of
real I want to say ambition is
versus a shritha uh we we recognize the
position from yes and uh Tata played a
very theoretical sharp and very forcing
line with C3 C2 C4 not the C3 and look
what she did
G4 here of course I think it's our theme
we've been seeing G4 in so many of our
games F6 and look what tatapp did she
said I'm going to trap your Bishop I'm
going to play for G5 yes
as shritha was forced to play G6 so that
she's ready to drop back with the bishop
aha said Tata
no ah no Batman I'm going to play Rook
H1 so I can go H5 force you to play G5
and then your Bishop will be terrible so
ashrita said okay I'll meet you with
Bishop F7 when you play H5 I'll take it
okay
well okay that kind of opens up uh the
king side and with the move Knight to E3
Tata is saying okay now now we're
talking let's go actually I like this
move Knight is free but it's all
incredibly forcing and uh sharp chess uh
by tatev and uh this looks like some
some seriously good home brewed uh
variation uh that tatv came today with
again very ambitious and lastly I was
looking at Arena Crush where it was
Arena Crush
there she is against Talia again one of
these wonderful imbalances
majority for Talia on the
Queen side majority for arena in the
center also the center I always like
those Central majorities a big moment
right here Talia could have played the
move G5
because the idea of course is if I could
get the bishop to move well there goes
the pawn but you might win this one
immediately goes to my voice
three after a five also I don't know
right exactly so tell you said well uh
you know I I would like to play G5 but
maybe not six times play rookie eight
and I'm expecting D3 D4 uh by Arena and
again I'm seeing very very ambitious uh
play by uh the white side yes let's see
if uh Talia again one of those players
who's drawn all of her games I teased
her that the person
did you become so solid Ivy come on tell
you you know because she has a
reputation of really a player swings for
the fences it's very normal for her to
have a plus score yes but to get there
by winning six and losing four
so all of these draws are very very very
unusual for Talia we'll see how she does
today yeah I think so but she was
telling that it happened to her once yes
that she started slowly but then she
started to win some games it doesn't
look that great so today her position
I'm looking at the move D3 D4 and again
I do see oh G4
what's in the water today G4 and almost
all the games yes probably we can count
even games for G4 we have no G4 on the
board Okay so
I mean is this Arena's way of saying but
now there is no Queen H5 and yeah but
there's no G5 either because now the
bishop will come back and keep a Pawn on
E5 maybe this is just a way of Arena
saying you know you don't really have
that many good moves uh I see it in a
different way I see it as this move
rookie eight is
uh black is ready to go Knight f8 97
because how else are we going to involve
The Rook we need to go Queen D7 and Rook
to d8 right so I need to get the Knight
to G6 but the queen on D7 that's a Tempo
against H2 look at The Rook on d8 that
will be a Tempo against D D3 a Tempo
against H3 Tempo against E3 so I see
this move G4 as a a little bit too slow
actually from my taste I think the night
coming
here and potentially even to H4
um that might have let some of White's
Advantage slip we'll see uh ambitious
play by some of the players I'm seeing
here what about you Christian what are
you oh you got the Tata game on yeah
yeah that should that one is so much fun
to analyze because there's so many plans
for both sides and actually that went
with this move Queen to F3 now what
worries me about the position and uh is
status time management right now tatev
is down to her last 18 minutes against
one hour and 13 minutes for ashrita so
almost a one hour uh time difference on
the clock now ashrita was blitzing out
her moves up to this point G6 Bishop to
F7 she still had one hour and 30 minutes
and I remember a game between Tate
and Alice Lee at the American cup with
this same exact setup so ashrita was
definitely prepared for at that one to
face that one Bishop to F7 H5 I have to
say playing this position with the black
pieces with the G file opening up like
this I would be scared in the position
she isn't because after King to h8
Bishop to G4 Bishop to F4 Queen to F3 a
lot of ideas
um are uh in the position one of them is
this move B3 what upon sacrifice but for
what well the pawn sacrifice is that I'm
going to activate my Rook I'm going to
go root to B7 and now you have problems
defending uh at this Pawn if you try to
go Rook to D3 the problem is that after
A4 I'm going to at some point it force
you to take and then Rook takes B to
come in the position and your king is in
trouble now if you Castle yourself then
after Rook to G8 you're going to be in
some danger right so you cannot do that
and the Knights are a bit Superfluous
right now because they're defending uh
themselves they cannot move either of
them the Knight is very very passive you
cannot jump to F5 or D5 where you would
like to get that Knight on E3 because
you're dropping the Knight on Cito so
you have to be very careful this is a
key moment and by the way after Queen to
F3 Rook 2 C7 was played very quickly by
ashrita now Rook to C7 invites finally I
get to cement the pawn structure as it
is I don't want to see any b3s in the
position I don't want to attack my Pawn
on C4 uh in any fashion so let's go B3
let's solidify the position for white
but still this game is up for grabs
anybody could win this one and with the
time uh taking down is going to be very
difficult for uh Tate especially to make
the right decisions nevertheless from a
strategical point of view ashrita has
some problems in the position especially
around those light squares so a very
very intriguing one this one is and the
game between Jennifer you and Alice Lee
and you guys were pointing out the fact
that Jennifer is taking over the
initiative in this one and she is indeed
Knight to F6 was played Knight to G5 I
think another move that you guys were
mentioning
pouring pressure on F7 but also ideas
that Bishop takes E6 later on not only
that but and you guys were mentioning
that as well is the activity of the dark
Square Bishop how do I do that how do I
get the dark Square Bishop in play well
such as E4 perhaps right yeah in the
position I have a lot of plans for white
and as black you just have to sit and
wait uh for me to do something and for
me to attack you you don't have any
Targets in White's position and I have
to say I'm really feeling this position
for Jennifer I think she might be
um very close to taking down Alice Lee
and moving on to Five Points out of six
possible that's an incredible score yeah
five that would be five wins and one
loss and no draw yeah team
at the opening of the show Christian you
mentioned that she Jennifer that is had
won the U.S Women's Championship with
some monster school yeah
wow that is just um well Jennifer the
competition has been put on notice that
when Jennifer gets hot and starts
winning these games she she can be she
can run away uh with the event and then
we see our current standings as uh
coming into this sixth round of play so
nothing has changed yet because nobody
finished the scores for the game so
Jennifer is on the top as you could see
let's turn our attention to Rochelle
shame on us Rochelle versus Sophie
because this is actually quite amusing I
don't know what's in the water today but
G4 is topical I mean
Anastasia across the how many games have
we been seeing with G4 well Rochelle got
on the bandwagon as well I don't
understand the move oh she played it
okay let's see what happened after G4
Bishop C5 now I think she started to get
worried that maybe the move C5 to C4 and
Knight to E4 would be injurious she
captured on C5
Knight F3 Queen E5 Queen D2 we've caught
up to the players but oh look at this
move by Sophie she played Knight to D7
which is intriguing to be sure but I'm a
pawn Grabber why didn't she take this
Pawn uh we've talked about Rook G1 and
Rook G7 here
[Music]
E4 in this case so
um I mean there is H3
maybe she thought that such a situation
was not favorable for her uh 97 by the
way one of the great ways of meeting a
pawn storm is just to get your pieces
out of the way Pond storms often come
with Tempo so when there's nothing to
attack sometimes it just looks like
attack went nowhere
97.8 C5 went back the pawn and then who
knows maybe even a move like Knight A4
will take advantage of the fact move G4
was ambitious but maybe not wholly sound
it just and we have a question from our
social media Anastasia yes let's see
what our audience is going to trick us
with today Neil Bruce from BCC BC asks
okay do you think that Hans has
demonstrated with his performance in
this tournament that he belongs at the
USGS championship
well of course of course I mean he
actually
by winning I think one of the events and
qualifying to this U.S championships you
actually deserve to be here yes and
secondly I think so far so good he plays
decent uh games decent chess fights in
every game no question about it he
scored 50 thus far he won a game that
spoke for itself and disrespected
everybody
we're not what's wrong with us we're not
being disrespected honestly
maybe our turn will come soon enough but
yes uh for me too I'm with you uh he
qualified very deservingly so as the U.S
junior Champion he is here and as he
himself said I'm here to play the best
chess I possibly can and get everybody
under this him at the draw with linear
Dominguez one of the top players in the
world I mean he lost against Fabi but
the game he was foreign
Christian I jump in with an answer as
well I want to speak for yourselves guys
because I felt disrespected
he didn't even want to analyze with me
so I felt disrespected on every level on
every level the spiritual the mantle the
emotional he made it back uh to me in
round four after that interview and he
was very jovial in that one so right but
yes to answer the question he definitely
deserves to be here at the USS
championships okay and I think we have
one more uh question from social media
as well this one from Larry Schuler and
he asks yeah has a question how many
moves they had do a little player's plan
how about yourself okay yes sir my goal
normally is not to lose something in
couple of moves I mean the most
important not to lose a piece because
okay if you lose a piece during the game
really complicated so that's for you
it's just like you're trying to look
tactically ahead and just make sure that
everything is safe for these next few
moves not to blunder or something and
you know there are some type of
positions where you really have to push
yourself to count well ahead you know if
you are not able to do this you can
forget about your any ambitious to
become a good chess player you really
some positions require this element
count in the head yeah some of them not
really I mean you don't need to do it
from one basically right so you know
some Theory opening so what about you oh
yes sir yeah I like what my good friend
Jose Raul capablanca said about uh
looking ahead and he said one move he
said one move the best move look one
move ahead and uh and it's the best move
and I think that it's really mixed for
uh for players to begin with but also
positions as you said I think there are
some positions that really allow them
cells for deep calculation and you could
go down what I want to say a very
straight and narrow path and you can
calculate very well other positions it's
sort of like there's a that there's a
huge number of options on each move and
a huge number of options for the
opponent so it's very difficult to
calculate those positions ahead
personally I'm usually in the let's say
temp like five moves I'm in the template
region
one particular game
forgot it was an ending I calculated it
wasn't different maybe yeah it wasn't
that difficult I wrote about it in in my
book on winning chess endings against
Cruz uh where it was like 29 moves but
it wasn't difficult because it was those
you know forcing forcing forcing for
forcing forcing and there are those
moments where the the position is so
sharp
and your opponent makes a move and it
wasn't something that you weren't even
looking at so like you really really get
surprised lead players do get surprised
it's rare I think that they're in the
like yourself and they take it a little
bit deeper uh depending on the position
Christian jump jumping with your
thoughts how How Deeply have you
calculated the game guys I think you
over analyze that question I mean what
can I add to that to those responses
um I was actually looking at this game
nice because this is a big one and it's
blowing up right now the game between
Alexander Orlando and Sam Shanklin but
to be honest let's see what happened I
take C5 Knight takes C5 F6 and now
Leatherman says yeah sure I'll take the
bull by the horns but I have equality in
the bag if I want it 1966 take on C6
take on D5 Bishop takes D5 this is where
we stand right now Queen to G6 track
Queen takes H6 King to G8 Queen to G6
King to h8 now
I will tell you what the engine is
saying the engine is saying that
actually white is better but I'm looking
at the position and I have a feeling
that lender man is just going to take
the draw in this position because what
you can do as white to improve the
position is take on D5 and then go Rook
to E1 right Rook to E1 maybe Rook to E6
the problem is that after Bishop to d8
which is pretty natural as well you
don't have a clear way uh to give the
Perpetual anymore and I will bring my
queen back
uh Queen here and then Queen to G7 and
this seems to well stop the checks at
least and we're going to have to assess
this position in which black is a piece
up but white has a couple of Pawns and
the compensation maybe even this this D5
Pawn will be hanging and will be
dropping in the future so right now
Alexander Linderman has the draw in his
pocket if he wants it maybe he's going
to continue after Bishop takes D5 and
Rook 31 let's wait and see yes and I
think we have one more question though
do we from oh well
we're ready we're ready to go and a
tweet from tree
tree
[Laughter]
well thank you very much yeah
what can I say I'm motivated by the
players uh I feel like I've got the best
job in the world I get to sit you know
in the front row you know nobody's
between me and the players and I get to
uh enjoy uh their play this is I mean it
doesn't get any better this is just
absolutely absolutely fun I want to go
to that game because there was a moment
here what uh the question just showed us
where's Sam sebion or are you Alexander
Lindemann where where where
uh
can't find it darn it there it is okay
so right here so obviously in this
position my puzzle Rush my wonderful
puzzle Rush Instinct said Rook to the H
file exactly I will I win let's go
that's a great so yeah why don't we play
H4 idea take G2
sign the score sheets yes so why don't
we so it has to be Bishop d8 based right
it's a it's an interesting point
doesn't really help quiz that helps a
lot
thank you very much
that's why we have to count in one
minute exactly okay exactly uh nice of
you to assist are you getting an assist
with that so I'm gonna go H4 uh you know
I could also do The Rook lift seminal
ideas Rook to D3 and G4 so the question
is if I take such a direct approach how
would the game go I'm assuming Bishop d8
yes right and then I'm assuming I take
and again you don't have time to
recapture King G2 and which one you have
to play
I don't know Queen H7 right for example
and the the pawn count at the moment is
three
yes so we can take for example Queen and
take one of six also right because I
don't see the way how to escape right
and then we're not very happy in this
case so it basically means that in this
position we first give a check okay so
you cannot put Queen H7 as we check
before King G8 right and then yes
and again we get the same problem that
how do I play for a win after Queen G7
uh again you know
I need like my Rook yeah that that was
why Christian was trying to play Rook T1
and Rook to E6 and that didn't work for
me
so I went back to this moment and I
thought okay
G4
yes maybe this is a little bit faster
and uh once again I'm seeing this move
Bishop to
d8.7 again exactly exactly that's
exactly right and again if I try I I
each time I come up one tempo short and
that was why uh Christian said I
therefore think uh Linderman's going to
take the repetition because even though
the computer says whites were choice
because white always has a Perpetual
check uh Bishop d8 in Queen H7 is a is a
very very powerful uh defensive idea yes
exactly yes so where would you like to
take us maybe we can check some games
oh yeah it was very very exciting I
believe that we have a actually a great
chance to speak with players after the
game that's also what's so fun
she was actually very tired in the
previous game do you remember the moment
when she actually was accepted the draw
she said that she was she was tired it
seems like she doesn't have enough
energy for the whole game and she's
getting tired after a few hours of play
which is very normal right right yeah so
you really need to push yourself to stay
focused and to really have the strength
to continue playing so this is what's
happening now so I thought that her her
chances could be better if she tries to
win after a couple of hours you know
create some attack and early in the game
Crush her opponents so maybe this is
what she was trying to do here you know
all this so well
she's definitely trying to crash through
I just don't know who's doing the
crashing yeah everything that's exactly
right Rook C7 she went C5 I very very
much appreciated this move B3 because
the when you have these pawns on C4 E4
they call it the maroxy bind and they're
using that expression for a very
specific purpose a bind I'm trying to
tie you up I'm trying to make it hard
for black to make counter play when you
play the move C5 and once you
immediately see the move B3 yes you
think immediately uh chirilla chaos
because some chaos is going on because
even though Tata has won a pawn with
Rook takes D6 Queen B8 uh
both players are playing you know
there's an attack going on in the center
of the king side but uh you can see that
black shritha that is to say is
definitely looking at her chances as
well and I see a three result game I
don't see you know just play on one goal
no no with the bind that moved B3 that
Christian recommended I really liked I
preferred I want to say White's position
yes guys look at the time what happens
what five minutes and 40 seconds for
tativ one hour and 11 minutes for
ashrita oh okay that's terrible that's
not that that's serious serious time
mismanagement no but this is what she
was talking about that she spends lots
of time to come out with all these plans
and then she has lack of energy at the
end of the game so I think that's a
problem it continues she couldn't manage
to solve it and the position is
complicated you really kind of try to
understand it well and yeah and you
spend lots of time I feel like these are
the 10 types of positions that you could
have two correspondents a grand Masters
look at for a month but still not be
absolutely sure what's going on that's
not the case because black is doing
great right he's just completely winning
completely winning yeah I thought so too
yeah yeah I thought that black had
crashed through and again if you look at
the whenever I'm in time trouble
seriously I maybe it's a strength maybe
maybe it's a weakness but I look for
simplification I I want to keep the
position simple I don't want it to get
complicated especially when I have less
time on the clock
yes yeah and I say look if if I win D6
later in the game because I played
Knight D3 I win it on my schedule uh C5
B3 takes takes why is the position
so good for Aretha because because I
have so many things going on the queen
side and I'm ready to break through with
Knight to B4 and Rook takes C5 and all
your pieces are on the other side the
queen is on F3 the bishop on G4 Knight
is on E3 you have to drop back all of
your pieces also a bit overextended The
Rook on D6 after I take on C5 and this
is why Queen to B8 was so precise
because once I take on C5 that's going
to come with a Tempo she could have
played Queen to A8 Queen to E7 a lot of
other Queen moves but Queen to B8 is the
most precise it puts a lot of pressure
on the B file as well as the rookon D6
and supports this move Knight to B4
which I have a feeling will be coming in
the next move Knight to B4 if you do
take on B4 I can take with the queen
everything is coming with Tempo in a
Black's position this one is looking
pretty much hopeless at this point for
today especially given her time
situation three minutes three minutes
guys and take it by the the way I I was
trying in all what you were saying
Christian to make a move for White and
the move I wanted to make for white was
Castle sword and I was trying to play
play castle short for white right here
right now night before and follow your
analysis yeah the computer wouldn't let
me do that because she played Rook G1
and Rook H1 unbelievable
so I can't even do castling and what
what Christian was saying was that after
the night lands on B4 this Rook is ready
to capture this Pawn on C5
unleashing you know all kinds of wow
the problem is that if you actually I
think uh King to F1 just Falls for Queen
to B5 uh-huh you don't need one to play
this that's a check I pick up the pawn
on C5 and your position collapses
by the way the Rook will be hanging
midnight on C2 will be hanging with two
minutes and Counting and that's fine you
got 22 but yeah
she's brought her Queen back with Queen
to E2 not moving her King yes and here's
where well night before I think you
suggested uh very wisely corrupted B6 to
stop the queen from dropping in on B4
Anastasia but uh despite the extra Pawn
for white it looks like black is having
all the fun by the way let's let's
calculate that so Knight to B4 yeah look
to B6 yes can I go a bit crazy and take
on C2 and take on B6 let's have a look
second B6 wow I don't know
yeah it looks interesting yeah I'm just
trying to Checkmate you somehow oh you
do have this B B6 Pawn which worries me
a little bit Queen B5 I don't know
something like that but now I have Rook
C1 and Bishop C4 Rook C1 and episode 64
yes and let's count the pieces you have
an extra piece at the end what else
[Music]
uh I could almost play B7 and invite
Rook takes because this move Bishop C8
uh but unfortunately I this check and I
it's like a rook yes it's a whole Rook
oh this is ugly I would love to Castle
so much I know I know I know it keeps
telling me it's illegal though it's it's
terrible imagine we've thought that
forgets about it and also make a place
cause right and this moment happened to
you in just history yeah it had happened
I believe in a game velamarovich was
white bent Larson was black bent Larson
was playing a sicilian in Villa marriage
it captured a knight on D7 he played
King takes D7 a few moves later he
played King E8 then he noticed did
Larson that villamarich was spending
quite a number of moves to prevent short
castles
a move that was actually illegal uh I
think that that combination works
Christian I think that the night before
and sacrificing the queen is a nice one
night before looks yup very very
distracted with the engineer does work
uh tempting
um another quick question for everybody
is what about Knight D4 yeah the idea
behind Knight D4 something kind of
similar but I'm just opening up this
attack I'm hitting the pawn on D4 and
I'm getting
again these marvelous attacks more or
less for free I like the night before
very much though I think that Tata never
mind her clock just the position has
gone South on her uh big time uh let's
just pick up Jennifer you and Alice Lee
for a quick sec
after we are seeing some action here yes
Knight to G5 yes it came Rook to f8 and
Jennifer couldn't contain her Glee and
yes uh I liked very much this move E3 E4
by the way just keeping control over the
position getting ready to bounce with
Bishop F4 she took let's see if it was
maybe let's see
well it's
two pawns for two and Rook for two
pieces right yes but also this Jeep on
double Pawn on G file that is true also
this B7 C6 and this trunk Center I mean
it's it's important I I must say I'm not
a fan of her follow-up if the follow-up
is Rook F1 a kind of a quiet move
Queen D5 I think this is the right move
for Alice Alice is thinking like hey
please let me let me try to you know put
as many barriers as possible for this
pawns exactly uh on on a really
wonderful day she could get to go G5 and
rookie eight she would be pleased I'm
not a big fan of what our tournament
leader has done I think she cashed in
her chips early with this move Bishop
takes E6 uh let's see what is going on
with Arena and Talia she did play
after oh that's as interesting after G4
Knight f8 Bishop back B6
G5
D4
wow
um that was quite a mix of Mexican
friends yes right of different plans
normally maybe she wanted to play Queen
H5 but then this trip on this hanging so
she decided to play D4 I'm not sure I'm
a big fan she took she decided to take
um
one thing uh okay these are general
rules but they're so important and they
have so much truth to them
when you're defending trade pieces yes
when you're defending be very reluctant
to trade pawns trading pawns means that
you're opening up the position
trade pieces so in this position Talia
is afraid she's afraid of the move D5
the bishop moves and then as you say
Anastasia Queen H5 so I would be much
more
of the mindset that I will play Bishop
C4
and maybe okay
Rook F5 is a wonderful move really it is
wonderful movie
for example Knight age seven so I
defended upon so
I'm not opening up the position I'm
waiting for you to play a move like G5
so pardon me D5 so I can take the pawn
uh she has played uh d'Italia tags I
assume recaptures yes and we can see
what arena has in mind uh D5 Queen H5
isn't is she justified in her Pond
sacrifice
yeah I don't know maybe also in this
line with Rooker five um uh after Bishop
C4
still like we can try to ignore I mean
ah yes okay it's wrong and as expected
uh the players
in the between Linderman and shankland
King h8 will be a three-time repetition
by Perpetual check and I'll we'll have
our first result
the first one yeah Rook F5 let's see can
we do something here for for Talia um
this is a fun okay let's have fun yes G4
let's go G4 she tries to get rid of this
bone right and close the door
I want to go Queen eight I wanna I wanna
exactly I want to flip the script and
say I forgot exactly Rook F5 here wow
you see and this is the other nice thing
about being a commentator yes any
blunders any problems I'll take my move
back yeah we can sacrifice
I like it I like to move Rook F5 because
otherwise I was I'm sure you would kill
me just uh well I'm kind of hoping that
I will uh get my pieces into the game
whereas the move Rook F5 is uh certainly
very very challenging jump in uh the
water's fine in the ladies section uh
we're throwing all kinds of patties
Christian yeah no I mean uh definitely
what Irina is doing right now is uh
quite correct and she's correcting her
assessment as well in fact the best way
for black to continue is to give the
pawn back right away with the move G4
yes give the pawn back and I'm not even
going to take it immediately because if
I take it you go Queen to H4 followed by
Knight to G6 you put some immediate
pressure on G4 but what I rather do
I think she will start with D5 it makes
a lot of sense right because once again
the difference is if you take take and
now you go D5 I have time yes exactly
right so what I have to do is first go
D5 and then I take back D7 no no no
yeah just for fun
yeah but maybe Checkmate on the board
thank you very much you want to go to h8
sure I'll give you a check yes
and now it's a check yes right yeah
that's a lot right right so uh this is
the position and I look also 38 minutes
I guess 19 minutes Irina is warming up
in this competition back-to-back
victories
um I'm trying to remember against who
should be Alice Lee was it I don't think
it was
true
that was that yeah that was the king and
pawn and yes that was remarkable that
she didn't so she won a fantastic game
in the last round against
Nova and yes this one maybe our
producers will listen
out but anyway she's having great
tournaments so far and I would say she
already warmed up like she's warm enough
she's she has that's what she said she
won already some games but that's what
she's yeah she starts winning it's going
to become much easier to continue the
streak and this is what we're seeing
right now putting a lot of pressure on
her opponent and in fact Talia played
the move Bishop to C4 but as you guys
were mentioning and this is the very
natural move in the position Rook to F5
let's go yes I'm attacking the pawn on
G5 it feels like I'm breaking through at
this point with the white pieces uh
check this out though
we did not even consider this move right
yeah but what if I take take take on B6
right ah but check this
if she finds this move first oh you're
actually going to be a whole Rook down
so right now you have to take on B8 or
if you take on C4 I take on B6 this is
completely over you take here but it
doesn't matter I go uh Rook to C1 the B
Pawn is going to be caught so I give you
a check I exchange and then I go Rook to
B8 and that finishes the game because
you don't have if you would have the
pawn on B7
you're probably winning right yeah
you're probably winning with white but
you're not in that situation so you're
actually losing so this is a tragedy of
one time Always by the way also that
I've done to her last minute one minute
against one hour three minutes and 50
seconds just uh pure domination in this
one I have to say from Australia on the
clock the clock was a big factor putting
a lot of pressure on her opponent by the
way uh our producers bailed this out by
explaining that Irene had been begum and
ashrita in back to back victories and
this it's still I I still have questions
about the arena versus Talia position
because after the move G4 which was not
played again in the game Bishop C4 was
talia's decision and Rook F5 was the
response yeah in case of G4 uh Christian
was getting excited by the move D5 I was
wondering okay if I drop back with a
bishop I'm assuming it has to be E6
related because if you take the pawn or
you're doing me the biggest favor now
I'm thinking I'm just recapturing it if
you want to win an exchange by all means
please do be my guest I'll have a a
pretty powerful night there so it must
be that in this exact position that
this is a gorgeous breakthrough
something like this is probably what
Talia did not want to see which is why
she played in the game Bishop C4 and
Rook F5 on the board as we prescribed
looks like Advantage Arena and I'm sure
arena is thinking I've got a wonderful
attack if you play Knight H7 like
defending this Pawn I think it was
played a move like D5 uh cuts the bishop
now uh H7 pawn and I'm ready just I'm
just so ready to play Queen D4 here
feels like uh uh a lot of um
momentum I want to say going on and
maybe that's not the only move as well
Knight H7 uh sorry did you say Knight H7
on the board it was played yes okay now
I think you don't have Queen H5 because
there is G6
like you were trying
to squares but yeah I mean everybody
should be so careful right right
nice well with one result in the opening
open let's take a look at the standings
before we go on break there it is so out
of seven games we have only one game
which already finished in a draw Alex
Slenderman made the dragon soundtrack on
all the other games are still all that
the players are still in the plane hole
I will put it this way
and we're gonna go on a commercial break
and we'll see you on the other side
thank you
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame
Cutting Edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art Innovative programming
explores the intersection of Chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and welcome back to round six of us
championships hello hello everyone I I'm
still looking at these ladies games I
mean those those uh breaks are too short
for us as really a lot of uh things are
going on in these games and the game of
Tata by the way has really worked out
fantastically for ashrita when we left
it we saw this I think both players had
a mutual blind spot at this moment this
was this Rook B6 I remember yesterday we
were checking this out this is like a
really nice hidden tack hidden tactic in
the position Knight takes Pawn takes and
you kind of see some kind of geometry
going on here if only we could play
Bishop C4 if we play Queen takes B6 Pawn
takes well this is actually favorable
well winning in fact for white but by
moving the move order mixing up the move
order with Bishop C4
first this is really really pretty and
ashwitha could have won on the spot like
this again a mutual blind spot it
happens both players Queen E8 Knight
takes Queen A4
and tats have suddenly realized uh oh
things really are not going well at all
the Knight on C2 is under attack the
pawn on C5 is under attack the best she
could find was 93 Queen takes E4 Bishop
F3 Queen B1 check forcing the king to
walk to the G file uh srita God and Rook
G7 check and after Queen
A2 black is just doing great what about
Knight G4 move could we play kingage 3
here I think it's the same thing right
that king would still the queen was
going to A2 to protect the bishop and
there's really not much you can do about
Bishop E6 coming your way
by by the way a Tata of no time also and
a very difficult position has fought her
way to this moment and I think more
moves on the board so right now the only
move should be either a queen B6 or
queen D6 right okay yeah try to spot
that F6 Pawn okay so in case of Bishop
G4 we have Queen F6 check first yes
foreign that's the problem though right
I mean big problem yes it is one of I I
mean as you start learning chess and
going up the ranks one of the things
that really you've become so Focus
and now we have to disappoint you they
made the time control don't disappoint
me I'm very happy that uh Todd epic
because she was so calm and what
everybody was looking for drama I
certainly was counting the drama moment
uh the problem is uh you really start to
uh respect pins and appreciate pins and
the whole point is once a once a piece
is pinned as The Rook is pinning the
Knight to the king all you do is you
load up against the pin peas and whether
it be Queen B6 or queen D6 for tatv
you just hit the pin piece this time
with the pawn F5 and that's it that's
That's All She Wrote Queen E7 no we
don't even have any tricks here some
kind of check Perpetual check but Bishop
goes to G8 and exactly exactly not
working six software like Bishop G8 and
then I think I'm always captured you're
able to double check yeah
um so I think I can be even more direct
after Queen D6 for example especially
yeah yes maybe I can go with E4
also oh it's a nice choice you mean oh
nice choice yes that's a very nasty one
because then you're doing everything
with a check exactly yeah yeah that's
much more forcing indeed E3 E5 E4
uh nice nicely spotted it's ugly yeah
the situation is ugly let's turn our
attention to our uh leader in the ladies
Jennifer you we really liked her
position and then I felt that something
had gone wrong in Jennifer's
calculations when she chose this move
Rook H1 to F1 why sacrifice our piece
for F7 and E6 black wasn't threatening
to do anything we could have played
these useful moves
E4 King B1 very useful little moves
after Queen D5 Alice said let me take
this Pawn I'll uh I'll go after this
Pawn on A5 I'm not uh
I'm not uh uh against uh winning pawns
after all I mean
but I did have a couple of extra phones
exactly exactly
and you start thinking
this night on D7 has no squares
especially with the A5 Pawn but now the
Knight does have a clear pathway Knight
V6 to C4 and uh well we just have to
make sure that we we're ready to meet
Queen takes G7 with a move like Rook F7
so we can
keep the attack going
I'm going to say that Jennifer this is a
three result game it's by no means white
only whereas a while ago I really like
White's position so something has gone
wrong here for Jennifer maybe she'll
write the ship well it's too
straightforward right I mean this maybe
she could wait a bit and enjoy her
Advantage but um I don't know maybe I
don't know who is Rochelle's coach but
Rochelle's coach is sitting there saying
Rochelle whenever you Castle short
don't do it when your Pawn is on G4 I
mean take that pawn and pull it all the
way back and then we can talk about what
you're planning to do I'm looking at you
yeah sir you're the secret coach of
Rochelle no I didn't I'm not a G4 guy
not even in um uh Wonder liang's game I
mean G4 that just that just stands out
in the position to me my goodness
um uh White I think is in trouble uh I
mean all day I would like to play uh
Black's position E I was about to say I
wanted to play E5 and E4 and suddenly E4
mysteriously appeared out of the board
out of the blue
is it
uh
yeah well you have to do something yes
exactly you have to do something
otherwise on a long term you probably
have worse position so you have to
probably try to find Dynamic way to
complicate like these things in this
game that's fair otherwise that's not
not going great I was wondering what's
happening to Hans game long time well
just before we go there yes okay sure
just before we go there Sam seven I
think just blunder wow the last move
check this out against Jeffrey against
Jeffrey a nice positional advantage in
the end game my pieces are a bit more
active than yours I have the pieces
pointed towards your weaknesses
specifically this point on B7 I'm
doubled on the E file I'm putting
pressure right in this position
check this last move Bishop takes B7 wow
I can start with Rook takes C3 now
has he missed this move so of course if
you take on C3
um sorry you cannot take on C3 if you
take on E5 first I take on C8 and I'm
attacking The Rook right clear I don't
have time to take on E3 because you take
the Rook on D7 and it's like Ping Pong
right you take this I take that also so
you're not going to get two pieces for
The Rook but what if I start with
Rook DC3 if you take with the pawn
simple I take only five you take back I
take on B7 yes easy to calculate if you
take with the Rook I take on E5 okay I'm
attacking The Rook
you can go Rook to C8 but after King to
E7 I still once you take only five I
take on B7 that's two pieces that's the
pieces for a rook and okay two pieces
for a rook maybe black Black is Black is
better black's your choice one question
yes maybe you have chances to equalize
this why but you're going to have to uh
labor for that quite a lot so and Rook
AC3 is on the board can we see the
reaction right now because I think it's
going to be one of uh one of shock
for Sam Seville
yeah
I think he just missed Rook takes C3
and one which is remarkable events
what a turn of events in this in this
game and by the way sound Savion is only
half a point going into this round
behind the leader of Fabiano caruana who
is winning his game
so if Sam doesn't manage to win this one
Fabiano could potentially go
on a one point Advantage going in the
last seven rounds
uh also it's very strange that because
we just had this convert uh conversation
we had this question from our audience
how many moves ahead do you think and
when you played the move Bishop takes B7
and understand there's some tactical uh
sequences you have to start to look at
all characters yes and Rook take C3 is a
capture that
you should have looked at but Sam seems
to have missed going in uh just sorry I
wanted to return our attention to
Rochelle and Sophia for just a moment
because while you did play this move E3
E4 you know the thing that attracts my
eye is Queen takes H2 mate and all I
need to do is get rid of the Knight on
F3 so
let me play Knight to D4 so that I can
play Knight takes F3 check and Rochelle
Sophie did catch the moment she did play
the move Knight F3 and Rochelle just
played King G2 and look at the final
position not the three king of three yes
he's taking a walk your King's taking a
walk uh B7 B6 dare I suggested and
Bishop B7 would definitely catch my eye
as I would seek to um
it doesn't look good at all for us oh
well I mean that G4 has a consequence uh
back over to you uh Christian and we've
been seeing G4 in a lot of games uh has
G4 gotten uh had a consequence in
Christopher you oh you have a different
position I have a different position
please yes I actually have the uh Hans
Neiman versus Ray Robson game okay
because uh Hans right now is in a world
of trouble let's take a look so it seems
like Ray Robson invaded with the Rook
via the second rank picked up a Pawn on
A3 got back to a to set up this very
very nasty threat on the G2 uh pawn and
Hans did not spot it what is that nasty
threat I'm talking about well take a
look after the move F5 Knight to C3 can
come on the board can you touch that
Knight no no Queen takes G2 that's a
Checkmate in one move so my guess is
that what Hans is trying to do at this
point is go F6
and try a Hail Mary on the king side
right the problem is Bishop takes F6 no
here you take back and I take back on e4
where's your mate if you take on G7 I
just move my Rook this Pawn is actually
helping me to stay protected right my
king is perfectly protected not only
that but right now with the move root to
C8 if you move the Knight I'm going to
drop back to C2 drop down to C2 and
you're in trouble because you have huge
problems on the second rank my knight on
e4 is perfectly placed I'm ready to go
Knight to F6 back and open up this
diagonal
also I have the a pawn my a pawn is
going to run down the board in any end
game with devastating consequences so
right now you're actually talking about
black windows 3 for example just to try
here at this position yes Queen to F3
and now for example yes okay and this is
the type of end game I'm talking about
right
first of all I'm oppona second of all
I'm more active third of all I'm ready
to take another pawn and be two points
out and you don't have and by the way he
played it with five minutes and 21
seconds on his clock which by the way
it's a lot of Time
series that's uh that's a lot of time
for rain with three games right we've
seen him down to his last 30 seconds and
just playing on increment 15 moves uh
but in this one there's only 13 moves to
go till the time the second time control
good position winning position
objectively so definitely this one Ray
might be uh taking uh a clear victory in
his game against Hans Neiman well that
would be important because again five
draws for Rey a win uh takes over Sam
sevillion's position who was a half a
point behind coming into this game I'm
looking at the game of Arena Crush yes
yes yes I understand everything white
white has a very very nice compensation
for the pawn but sometimes you just have
to win it right and tally is kicking
she's just played this move Bishop back
uh remember when we put our Rook very
nicely on F5 and we all understood we
were going to play Rook F1 and crash
through with Rook takes F7 well I mean
Talia is putting the questions to her
opponent and again I like Arena's
position but how are you going to win it
I mean what would you recommend yes I
don't know I would maybe bring my Rook
back and to do for example yeah and
again I'm I'm playing a piece down yes
no questions far away so you try to
activate the G4 yes yes in order to on a
good day bring my knight to G4 maybe if
I could if you would be so kind as to
allow me to capture your Pawn on H3 and
then play the Knight to G4 be happier G5
I'd be happier still again you know you
you would like to just make these
wonderful full crashing moves and I'm
not sure because then you yes I don't
even have to take on H3 yes and go into
the complications uh as I say no no no
no and again I'm still looking at
resistant you know making it hard it's
not that easy yes Irina played oops
it looks like our two heavyweights uh
with the white pieces uh defending
Champion he's watching his title uh
float away yeah
six rounds behind you're right it's so
hard to get the uh how to get those
victories oh sorry he's going to be a
point and a half behind the Fabiano wins
right pardon me if I'll be on a win I
think a point and a half I'm not 100
sure but that sounds yeah right right
now I think he's one point behind yeah
right
50 even so if Fabiano wins his game
which it does seem like he probably will
Wesley is going to be one point and a
half with seven rounds to go that's a
lot of ground cover absolutely
seven rounds seven rounds to go yeah
we're used to just trying to count yes
exactly so many rounds yeah uh just
picking up with Jennifer and then I'll
turn to the open section for just a
moment Bishop takes D2 Queen take Rook
takes due to Queen A5 Queen
uh
uh D3 on the board and wow I don't think
you're ever going to get a better
opportunity to play a move like
19554 as right here right now I mean
once that Knight gets to B4 first of all
you can't kick it away second of all
it's just you know supporting this
Invasion and uh and she did it Alice 95
yes it's it's an active movement the
movie you want to play definitely
definitely the knights doing nothing on
F6 on the contrary you put it on B5 now
the question is it can you then follow
it up with C5 and get a very very
serious attack Brewing uh my first
impression is that Alice is for Choice
uh still I see it as a three result game
because
the two nights are not the best
uh against the minor pieces uh yes
exactly uh we'll definitely keep an eye
on that one and back over why did you
say that Fabby we've been saying that
for a while and we actually haven't
looked at his game that much so let's
take a look at what's happening in uh
that one night landed finally on C4 we
were discussing about the the potential
of this Knight landing on C4 or on F4
via d8 E6 and F4 he decided to go for
the C4 score specifically because white
played the move Knight to C1 and Knight
to D3 covering the F4 Square so what do
we have right now after the move Knight
to B4 Fabiano found this very very uh
cool move Queen to ca
hmm what does this mean well first of
all
do you want to exchange my bad Queen on
H3 that hasn't been doing anything good
question sure yes because once we
transition into the end game which
you're pretty much forced to do there is
no way uh nowhere to hide with that
Queen you're dropping a pawn if you go
Rook to B1 I'm going to take on B2 or
take on A3 that's going to be a pawn
down so he decided to try to look for
counter play with this move Knight to A4
not only that I'm protecting this Pawn
but I'm also looking and eyeing that
Basics query if I manage to go Knight to
B6 exchange the knights and cement the
position as it is I'm going to be fine
exactly why but you're not in time and
this was played A5 was played if you go
back Knight to D3 Knight to E3 it is
going to come and now you're forced to
sacrifice an exchange if you take on E3
I'm going to take back I'm not even
looking at your C2 Pawn C2 Pawn is good
enough
I'm trying to Checkmate you Knight H5
and Knight G3 is coming on the board so
for example if you go Knight to F2 I can
continue right to G3 take and now Bishop
takes F2 or take on H3 take on G3 take a
knight to H3 and Bishop sorry Rook takes
C2 with another reinforced Checkmate
right okay The Rook takes H3 followed by
Rook to H2 so really do this wow that's
cool and Rook to H2 pretty that's very
pretty yeah uh none of this by the way
is going to happen because he played a
knight to A2
but once again
what do you do after Knight E3 plays
itself plays itself right I mean in the
worst case you do this and you take on
oops
you do this and you take on a C2 that's
the worst case if you don't see Knight
to H5 you're still completely winning
that worst case is my best gift
that is pretty good indeed um so Fabiano
looks like he's just simply breaking
what would have happened if Alshon had
played the more natural looking knight
to D5
after A5 yeah Knight to D5 maybe just
take to follow it up uh Rook takes yes
please Rook takes Knight E3 I I'm trying
to keep material quality
you take on A5 let's say I think you get
checkmated
good enough I I think you get checkmate
here good enough yeah you don't have
this G1 Square this bishop is actually
extremely powerful on E3 I take on G2
next move this is this is it if you
don't have your pieces to help your king
yes no Knight is only four rookies only
by the way this is for Fabi this is like
a a dream coming true I mean we we spoke
in an earlier broadcast about this up
and down 2022 especially his second half
in the candidates where he had been
keeping Pace with nepo but then he
really fell off and he hadn't had a very
good 2022 uh yes he won this um uh what
was it the Fisher random or no
against alireza but he's really looking
for a big bounce back and plus three in
U.S Championship would really really uh
do wonders yes exactly and he's I mean
increase his mood definitely yeah
self-confidence crazy game going on with
a wonder and Christopher I get a has to
analyze that as we turn it over to
Christian with the guest in studio
and here first of all welcome uh back to
the studio a draw with the black pieces
against Wesley saw the defending
Champion how would you assess your
performance in this game uh yeah I
played pretty solid uh I think the
opening was uh very quiet at some point
there were some chart options like he
could play this E5
E5 move after I played E6 I I believe
was possible
oh yeah here I thought that E5 takes on
F3 yeah Queen F3 and Bishop takes C5
Knight B5 but I thought I can play 97
and
um sacrifice The Exchange and after
Queen A8 for example yeah King D7 takes
takes the Rooks are not doing much and
my knight is going to land on D4 and
I thought this is this is pretty good
good conversation for you yeah but uh
yeah but mostly of course it's a very
solid opening and then uh I think uh
after uh when I when I took only two and
two gun before and played D5 that was
the very solid decision as well maybe
you can play five if I really want to
give the tension instead of taking no
instead of taking on on E2 and on B4 you
skip the Knight only four and maybe play
F5 and it's probably a good position but
I thought that uh what I did was pretty
uh solid and maybe I'm just tiny bit
worse but not really much because we're
getting ambitious during the game did
you think that you have a pool in in not
really I mean I if I wanted to try to
keep the tension then I would go F5 but
I saw the other way and I I saw that I'm
equalizing and and I went for it
um
very concerned at all by this expansion
with H4 uh yeah well I wasn't thinking
about H4 but I thought in general that
he can keep detention and move like Rook
fd1 or something like that but uh yeah I
thought I can take and and play Queen C7
or something and and then eventually
we'll be fine but I don't know maybe why
this is a bit better but I thought it's
nothing too serious and I should be able
to to equalize nothing to be worried
about but uh yeah the way we played I
mean Ed of course if Queen F3 here it's
nothing to worry about because I can
play Rook AB8 and C5 T4 and this is six
second take on C6 leading to a draw
which hand game
take take this yeah five or
yeah
there is no reason why you would be
worse here
so C5 but uh yeah I have this D4 because
if white is in time to play D4 then with
this Pawn on on C5 eventually my my
Bishop on B7 could be
um passive and also the the other Bishop
gets close but just in time to play D4
and uh yeah then here I thought I was
just out of danger
and it seemed like he felt the same way
because you guys were kind of already
speeding things up Russia into that
equal position there's no way for either
side to create chances here I believe
yeah
linear how would you assess your
performance up to at this point still
seven rounds to go well it hasn't been
great but it's uh it's not bad either I
I still have some some white games I
already play my games against the most
of the top guys so I'll try to use my
chances in the in the rest of the game
especially the wide games especially now
that Fabiano seems to be speeding up in
the tournament it seems to be winning
against elshon as well yeah
of course uh the when when father is in
shape he can really score like that uh
then I mean if you keep scoring like
that there won't be much of a fight for
for the championship but uh but okay
still there there are some rounds to go
and and a lot of things can happen so
um for for myself I have to try to use
the chances that I that I get and and
try to to press a bit plenty of routes
to go a lot of energy to be spent will
let you recover and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you uh Lanier
just turning our attention between hands
and Ray and I'm going through uh
variations that I'm seeing here when we
left it we just left it at this part
I'm sure that when Hans in his mind had
seen this attack with F5 F6 he just way
way way over evaluated uh his attacking
potential the move Bishop takes F6 is a
really a cold shower because after
Knight takes F6 she takes F6 this threat
of mate in one precipitated Knight F3
and again he's thinking you know of
course he's just two moves away you know
three moves away from Checkmate but
Knight takes D1 comes with a nasty uh
shot after for example if you take on F6
I've got Queen A7 chat and why is that
important
oh oopsie Daisy and Jack
Queen F2 yes
I go to
H3 and then what you scared me to death
I scared myself again for some reason I
didn't feel completely overlooking yeah
good morning St Louis
oh my goodness uh what was I you're so
convincing yourself
immediately very good I did it with Elan
too I just gave away uh uh Ray's uh Rook
yes very nice do you need any help yes
sir Queen A7 check why did I think that
boy talk about a blind spot Queen A7
check King H2 how do we protect against
this idea according to 5.7 Is It Anyway
to do it
you can take it in a move uh King H1 for
just a moment but just a second hold on
hold on hold on no no don't don't try
yes sir don't try don't try go back go
back go back yes because if King for
example there is looking for he started
with King you know why he started like
this because I'm sorry yes what did he
do he started with King h8 King AJ no no
no
six yeah on F6 and came to h8 oh you
start with red pigs and now King AJ yes
okay one F6 and now King because if you
give check then Rook a E4 will come with
a Diya Queen H7 Checkmate and Rook H4 uh
I don't think so no no actually
after the king tonight G5 but the whole
point is is that there's a mate on one
so there's no Knight G5 the moment you
go Queen H6 you're not following it up
with Knight G5 ever aha so just King h8
and then you have to play Rook takes D1
wait and we've caught up to the players
by the way but now we can go check and
maybe
I like that
guys yes when it rains it pours and this
is exactly what's happening right now
with levon's position in levon's game in
his first U.S chess championships
he blundered oh no take a look at this
he played the move Rook to C4 and
allowed Queen to H1 Chuck King to E2
Queen to B1 attacking the bishop on B2
so let's say you just simply defend it
right Knight to F4 is going to come on
the board oh my God and actually just
finishing the game because you cannot
take Rook on the edge you have to take
otherwise you get checkmated this will
be a Checkmate your king goes to E4 and
yeah good luck surviving this one right
to D3 Knight takes F2 Knight to H5
Knight to F6 there's plenty of ways to
Checkmate that King so after Queen to B1
Levon is well Knight to F4 is by the way
a pre-move If you defend this [ __ ] Pawn
B2 in any way shape or form I'm going to
go Knight to F4 you're going to take I'm
going to take back I'm going to capture
the exchange and then I'm going to start
hunting your king and Checkmate it
there's no compensation let's pan on
levance right now levon's reaction must
be one of disbelief
he missed this and right now he is in
deep trouble with the white pieces guys
once again yeah back to back losses man
that
that's painful I'm going well yes oh he
what he did Queen A3 defending the
bishop but in this Knight F4 is begging
the we played
darouche really kind of rocking like
okay my turn and why isn't Knight F4 uh
because I have to play Rook takes F4
and I'm assuming you don't want it to
capture but Queen D3 is also right can
be unpleasant Queen D2 followed by Queen
Victoria's yeah if you if you go King
you want Queen the two is a maid right
right so Knight F4 I have to take with
the roof taking with the pawn that's
just suicide so Rook takes F4
not do I yeah Queen D3 right if I take
the rook and allow Rook takes
oops
that's not what you want to do so you
have to play Queen D3 check and I have
to play King F3 otherwise it's Chuck
maybe otherwise it's Checkmate walking
stepping back would allow Queen takes D2
and mate and now Queen D5 let's follow
it up
ah yeah you cannot go back because again
Queen to two queen D2 is made so if I if
I drop a rook in the way you
you'll probably play F5 and then that's
a uh oh oh if I step in the way of my
Rook now now you think that yes that
makes sense and E for something similar
if I can just simply uh in fact take on
D2
take on D2 and set up I think oh G4 yeah
oh oh oh oh so let's keep going with
this variation actually Queen D2 Rook F5
mating to move so sorry Queen D5 no E4
E4 E4 or queen two Rook F5 yes but now
there's just Queen D1 Rook D3 that's a
check uh yes my king doesn't escape
unfortunately
and uh sadly for Lavon uh ronian uh fans
he's winless Darius as well but hasn't
one of these things yeah uh with a
victory darush would uh get back to 50
and he'd feel a lot better about himself
and Lavon will be thinking oh my gosh
yes my uh debut at the US championships
has been a disaster yeah I remember the
one having one of those disastrous
tournaments as everyone has yeah like in
Berlin candidates you know he started to
lose one game second and then actually
it really finished really bad yes there
during this candidates tournament so I
just really hope you'll
managed to put himself together after
this game exactly yes let's move on to
the house Neiman because I think we're
going to see a resignation there oh very
soon very soon Queen 32 that so we we
left it at this point Rook takes D1 Rook
uh G8 King H2 defending the pawn on G3
again maybe on an incredibly lucky day
you get something like Queen H6 a bit
Queenie for that's that's a boss move
first of all defending H7 menacing G2 as
well as the knight uh Rook it's D7 Queen
E2 threatening mate so what green H3 you
have to play place Queen takes F3 Rook
takes F7 I think Rook G2 is the previous
right now
oh oh very very nice GM geometry and
Greenwich he played it oh okay
is here
okay wow very nice win for Ray but I
must say his opening was a disaster and
somewhere around these parts right here
I thought Hans was all for Choice uh in
this position I thought Hans had played
it really really well and somehow he
never ended up capturing this bishop or
trying to win a pawn instead he allowed
rages to take over the C file which is
very perplexing and for Ray
it's his first win of the day he gets to
plus one uh he gets to look around and
say how am I doing I hope I can come
here right you're doing well yeah
and let's see I wonder uh versus uh
Christopher uh because position got
really sharp right here uh when we well
we left it quite some time ago yes so
Christopher invited complications with
the move Rook f8 of course I can capture
the spawn on E5 but much more attractive
is the move 96. I cross up the defense
of the Rook on H6 and gift
me The Rook on f8 okay let's trade him
off no says a wonder I want to look at
this I'm attacking the bishop I'm
attacking the Knight I'm attacking The
Rook
Rook F1 trade takes
and look at this by the way I'm also
told there's been another result yes we
have a draw between Sam Sabian and
Jeffrey shrunk oh because we thought
that Sam had missed I I think so yes we
thought he will play descending with
rook and pawn against two pieces
we'll take C3 and then what happened yes
it was clutching his head like why did I
allow this yeah so it's it's still a
pawn yes rook and a pawn
so they traded all those he managed to
uh very very good yes and by the way big
breaking news as uh tatev uh goes down
to defeat we expected that yeah she was
a very bad position boy but the results
are coming in fast let's go to Le Mans
game also because we might be seeing a
resignation in that one as well okay
they went uh straight into the line that
we predicted with Queen D5 check all on
the board yeah yes so now if King G4
remember we discussed ethics for simply
yes with the moment when the Rook is
blocked exactly it feels like a duck
somebody put the duck in the way him
Rook takes G7 oh boy oh boy oh yeah
with all this dark memories no no I mean
I think my brain got rewired at that
party I mean boy there was a lot of
hands you guys were giving me a lot of
help but uh hats optic to uh Katya she
took us all down yes exactly nice and
the problem is there's just simply no
way to continue the game you're not only
losing the rook and you're going to be
down in exchange actually your king is
getting checkmated as well mostly let's
see most of the variations the vultures
will gather if you tell me that there's
a Checkmate on the board something like
this I think that's a very easy way to
do things and you cannot hide you cannot
go between King H3 Queen H5 that's a
Checkmate that's brutal it's painful
that is very very painful so I'm losing
material and uh but this is how they say
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's no
hiding Let's uh and Lavon uh clock times
nothing really terrible three minutes
for uh Darius but I think we're already
at move actually no it's move 28 there's
still plenty of moves but with the
increment and an easy position right now
I think this is pretty much over and you
can see it on the ones uh body posture
as well right he's looking away from the
board he's trying to remember where did
I let this one slip and it was only a
few moves ago when he allowed that Queen
to H1 Queen wait wait a minute can I can
I throw in uh let me try E4 once oh he
played rookie for he played rookie but
had he played E4 what was our
organization Queen takes D2 and how
about Bishop takes E5 in this
contact is the same thing Queen D1 Rook
D3 Queen D of course the same thing
you're absolutely right I was I had some
dream that you were checking me and I
was running for the hills but I'm not
running anyway no there's no running no
there's no running yeah there's no
crying okay so he broke at least he's
not getting checkmated
F5
Bishop C3 so he's hoping that he'll have
a safe home on E2 so let's see does c
actually have a c so for example I mean
if Queen takes or what yes can you do
okay
inviting a Perpetual yeah
exactly
I'm not going to take that Perpetual
okay what if I continue F4 F4 but yeah
yeah F4 is good actually yes you cannot
take it takes a four we're in The Rook
a little bit more worried about losing
my king too yes oh dear F4 uh very very
disturbing uh so you probably have to go
what Brook I have to wear maybe Rook F3
but yeah I mean
I really want to Checkmate you so let's
let's figure out the checklist for a
brief moment there is looking at trying
to get a a crazy pipette but not enough
uh you want to Checkmate me okay I think
with F4 so I have to start with that
four the problem is a kind of a
desirable move like Rook here gives me
the time to set up a threat so F4
and I can't take I can't move my Rook
Rook F3 for example so before it was
actually played first yes but we're
probably headed to this variation
uh without the check he played F4 first
okay awesome and perhaps this is the
better way to do things I agree I agree
this is uh yeah I mean nobody's running
away and it's entirely possible that you
would like to keep the D file open for
just a moment like let me put a few very
bad moves just uh apologies everybody
but a few very bad moves so that I can
just show why we would not want to play
Queen D3 right away nice and Checkmate
and a Checkmate exactly exactly so yeah
yeah yeah it looks good it looks good it
feels good uh Rook uh Rook to F3 on the
board and now having said that having
said that instantly Queen D3 check
exactly and another draw uh
yes yeah but I I think we have a guest
in studio or not quite yet we do excuse
me we do have the guesses too we do have
a guest we are with ashrida eswaran
after her second Victory back-to-back
victories he took down Anna zatonski now
abrahamian how do you feel right now it
feels really good Tatum has been like a
very problematic opponent personally for
me because I think we've played like
maybe nine ten times and I don't really
have a good record against her
um so it's finally nice to win
especially with block against her and it
felt like you were so well prepared out
of this opening and thought if I'm not
mistaken played something similar at the
American Cup against Alice Lee did you
prepare based on that game yeah I did so
actually it's my again my first time
playing this opening um and I think we
had a game in the summer in July and I
was black then too and I played a
terrible game inside this time I just I
wanted to be more aggressive and I think
playing the Sicilian was the way to go
okay
take us through the opening phase this
was the first time you played this
Russian yes oh wow
um and
I was actually I think if you saw my
clock I think I was I remember I knew
the position to like move 21 or
something like de3
um but yeah I saw that you know she
originally back in the days used to play
after instead of C4 after Bishop F6
Bishop F6 she used to play the C3 line
um all the way here yes yeah
um instead of C4 here yeah C3 yes so and
then recently especially her game
against Alice and then I think she had a
title Tuesday game over the summer as
well she started playing the C4 move
um
and I just so I was well prepared um and
I think she played the same plan with
Queen F3 G4 H4 so I was just looking at
this position and just got lucky that it
happened today
um but yeah she was spending a lot of
time
um did the rest day help with your
preparation you managed to check
everything all the possibilities it
definitely did but I didn't like
paired I did the normal preparation
because I also did have schoolwork to do
okay but yeah I was able to at least get
a little bit more than usual absolutely
so take us through the game after yeah
so here yeah after Rook H when I looked
at this bishop F7 and did this idea of
taking on H5
um and so you were still in your
preparation at this point wow and so I
looked at night ce3 I just
um and I think I was planning to play
Bishop G6
Knight F5 and Bishop or not Bishop
Bishop B5 first yeah yeah Bishop G5
first yeah yeah Bishop G5 first Knight
F5 and Bishop G6 and this is a very
complicated position okay
but I thought I'd take my chances
especially since she was low on time
that was some Trend I saw like in her
previous games as well in this
tournament
um and I had the two Bishops and I felt
confident that you know there's a lot of
complications there and it felt like you
were also willingly putting a lot of
pressure on her time that was part of
the strategy as well
I think last couple of times I played
her she managed her time pretty well and
so I felt like I had to put the pressure
on her from the beginning of the game
this time absolutely and you played this
more Rook to D7 taking to a trade yeah
we were looking at the position with a G
file open things were looking dangerous
for you uh were you concerned at all or
I was slightly concerned I think instead
of uh instead of C5 actually on move 26
um I thought Knight F5 was a possibility
because if I go Rook D7
um I thought my age four I'm not sure if
it works but Rook C7 and Knight G6 ideas
and I was worried about this
um but I so I suspected on Knight F5 I
had to give up the D6 Pawn like I did in
the game and go for counter play
um how would you do that that's a good
question
um I thought Bishop takes C4 Knight
something like this
um
there was it looked really hard though
if she played this way though Knight to
my five yeah that was the movie you were
concerned yeah that was definitely the
movie I was concerned about
um and I think here yeah I think
there were some lines where I wanted to
like even sack my queen I think Bishop
G8 was the move perhaps Bishop yeah
Knight F7 and then uh takes maybe with a
bishop yeah with the bishop and then
played this position because
um by Dark Sword Bishop is good and
she's still can't castle and you have
some Knight D4 coming in yeah yeah
definitely looks like some solid
compensation in this one and uh let's
take a look at what she played she
played this move C5 and after that it
felt like you are taking over I think
she missed the move B3 I I'm not so sure
but after B3 ab3 Bishop B3 I think she
was already thinking a lot and after run
D6 Queen B8
um she played Queen E2
um and here I was looking at pause
instead of night before I think I was
consider considering like Bishop takes
E3 or even uh like just Queen yeah sp3
and then I think still night before like
some ideas of picking up the pawn on C5
and playing on but I thought night
before
uh without trading a pair of minor
pieces was better and then here when she
played Rook B6 I played Knight C2 and I
think she realized she couldn't take
back on C2 because a queen takes B6 and
Rook C2 yes
um
which I think she might have missed
initially because she started thinking
like for a few minutes here and then
played King F1
um and then here again I was debating
whether to go like Knight takes E3 fe3
um
and I think Rook B7
um
but I again I thought she was getting
away with everything here
um and so I decided to play Queen E8 and
queen A4
um
yes
and then take on e4
um
and and what if she goes something like
right do you want here Bishop uh yeah
a take on
five or Bishop C4 then take on C5 got it
it's just something like this yeah but
there's gonna be three I think maybe
queen of three maybe King G2 trying to
run away this is probably her best
chance I think
um
and if you go d8 maybe something like D1
or try to do something yeah along these
lines
cool and she played Knight takes E3 and
at this point you found this idea with
Queen to A2 Queen D3 Bishop E6 it
definitely got more messy than I
expected
um but I think she was just really low
on time but I felt like this should be
winning with F5 E4 ideas and her King is
under a lot of pressure here with the
two Bishops yep
um and it was indeed Queen 26 Rook 28
she exchanged but you gave her no chance
I was I looked at I think instead of I
thought Rook A1 Rook A4 was clever
because if I take then uh Queen takes E6
and she has chances there because my
king is weak's Queen of eight maybe some
perpetuals but I think I was lucky that
E4 I had E4 there
um and you saw this from afar yeah yeah
I saw this when I played Queen C4 I was
debating whether I could go E4 when she
played Rook A1 but I figured to have my
queen closer to the king and bring it
back and then very nice very nice a nice
way to finish the game ashrita a very
aggressive game you must be be feeling
good about let's say the bounce back
victories in the last couple of rounds
how I started I think this is the best
part again I'm just taking it
and today was a very important game
given our history but also given the
tournament situation guys any questions
for us just our congratulations
congratulations Sharifah keep it up very
very nice bounce back victories for you
thank you indeed and sum it up or is uh
some of these results from the ladies
that are coming in uh well I I want to
say results in the open we're coming in
please uh I'm assessing yeah so for
ladies we have two games only
one on one win one draw and here we have
five results already look for draws in
games of Wesley so Alex landerman same
seven Against Drunk and also a Wonder
made the draw with Christopher you and
we'll just keep this this graphic for
just a moment because uh a while ago
there was there was these white washes
with white winning game after game looks
like Fabi as a winning ending and darush
has a winning middle game at the moment
so we could be seeing three victories
for black very unusual after all of
those wins with the white but we're
going to go back to you Christian and
another guest video Ray a big victory
for you with black pieces plus one right
now how do you feel after this this game
I feel pretty good I mean it was a very
complicated game uh and I didn't have
that much time so I was a little bit
worried but yeah somehow in the end of
the game things went very well for me it
felt like he surprised you with his
opening Choice tell us about that yeah I
mean he played this three Bishop F4
which is a funny move I think Magnus
played it against Wesley once maybe and
he was kind of basically the first
person to do it and it was funny I think
the European Club cup finished a few
days ago and yeah a few days ago I saw
one of the the games where I played
Bishop F4 I think maybe white even won
or got a good position and I was
thinking oh I should probably just look
at this and then I completely forgot
about it of course I never expected him
to play it against me today so I
couldn't yeah I mean I knew D5 is is
trying to take advantage of the
bishopone F4 takes Knight takes Bishop
G3 C5 so this was actually the game
that's probably why I recognized it but
uh yeah after E4 and Knight D2 I had to
make a decision obviously I could take
the pawn but
yeah I was a bit worried I mean he's
just gonna play Knight F3 Bishop D3 E5
and I have this extra Pawn by something
like this yeah
you decided to get a similar position
but without the pawn on D4 how did you
come to that conclusion I I just wanted
to be as safe as possible but I knew I
might be objectively worse here
um I really wasn't sure I think this I
think just slightly yeah yeah I think
this plan of A5 was very nice
um
and I went to basically I just always
keep my Bishop on C5 now he can't kick
it with B4 and I'm always offering the
pawn he can always take it if he wants
but I'll just exchange light squared
Bishops and also bring this c69 yeah
Stakes you got [ __ ] by six here um
let's say Knight F yeah Bishop basics
for example yeah Bishop A6 I'll exchange
these Bishops and put the other Knight
in F5
and I'm down a pawn but my Knights are
great I was supported by this E6 pawn
and I should just be able to put
pressure on the the B Pawn and I felt
I'm not in too much danger in these
types of positions so I thought this was
a good practical uh and the assessment
agrees more or less with you yeah that
seems to be the case definitely
compensation but he probably should have
tried to take the pawn in some version
because I think what he did I must be
completely fine at least
um yep yeah some weird moves rookie one
and then then that H4 couldn't predict
these moves but actually Knight H4 was
was interesting
um it felt like he was trying to find a
way towards your King right yeah I think
also he just wanted to complicate things
as much as possible make me burn time
and then just flag me so
um so I felt like Knight takes G3 was
probably correct here otherwise I was
afraid he would get an attack Bishop B7
here Queen H5 was surprising I thought
he was just gonna play more positionally
just reroute the Knight to D4 probably
and I thought this was playable
um B5 or yeah maybe B5 Knight D4
um if I play B4 he plays A4 so I thought
this would be you know playable for him
Queen H5 was much more aggressive but
somehow I didn't really see what he was
actually going to do because even if he
brings a knight to G5 it takes a few
moves and I just play H6 and he goes
back so I like to B5 bring my Rook that
was completely off sides yes into the
game and I felt kind of safe on the
position just I was worried about the
time obviously so o'clock yeah I think
he was just going completely all out
putting trying to put uh pressure on me
because he gave this pawn and he went
for F5 very quickly and did you feel he
missed Knight to C3 or was it already
too late at that point I don't think he
missed it I think he probably if he
missed something it might have been
Bishop takes F6 next move which I think
was a good move and I think yeah this
probably just refutes uh this whole plan
yeah I think uh if not for Bishop to F6
you're actually losing so instead of
Knight C3 originally I was uh thought G6
would be safe and then takes let's say h
takes Queen H6
um like if he gets a rook to the H file
just get mated but it's kind of hard for
him to get there so at first I thought
oh I can still play Knight C3 but then I
realized his threat's actually 96 and I
probably just lose yeah yeah so then I
started calculating Knight C3 it looks
very dangerous after F6 but then I
realized Bishop F6 might actually just
be working so I spent some time but it
seemed like everything just just worked
so I had to go for it and here yeah I
mean he could have played EF and FG
um I was probably going to play Rook d8
I don't know that was the best but yeah
he really didn't have any attack here
and if he plays something like let's
just say Knight C6
Rook takes D1 Knight E7 check first king
takes G7 and let's say queen takes D1 I
mean I have many many things I can do
but one idea that's always nice is I
have this queen A7 checking H2 Rook
takes a G2 check and a lot of lines very
nice yeah yeah so actually a checkmate
yeah so he went for the other the other
way but
um unfortunately he's always tied down
to G2 so he can't bring his Knight into
the attack and so it should just uh not
be enough yeah yeah as long as you don't
blunder like Yasser did between A7 we're
not mentioning any names by the way
we're not mentioning any names of course
heathway chat and after that it was a
smooth sailing for you uh Ray
congratulations uh plus one right now
how do you feel about your chances to
potentially take it all home
oh I mean I think we're still not even
halfway through the tournament so that's
true uh yeah I mean my I had a kind of
difficult pairings at the start I played
most of the top guys so just kind of
got through with a bunch of draws and uh
yeah I mean obviously I'll take my
chances look for some wins but
everyone's super strong I'm just gonna
try to keep doing what I've been doing I
think I'm playing at a pretty good level
so um yeah I'm happy with how I'm doing
so far guys
congratulations Ray just a really really
nice uh Victory there hanging and
refuting the attack difficult but well
done Ray your first win and five draws
uh rest day was uh uh was very useful
for you yeah yeah
I was wondering how it was was it
difficult to play this position was not
so much time on your clock I mean it was
still sharp and you had to check all
these variations how did you do it where
you calm or you were nervous at this
moment oh I definitely wasn't calm I
mean I was uh I think I was on the video
could probably sound like jumping around
a lot but
um no I think at a certain moment in the
game I start to speed up a lot and when
things yeah got extremely direct at the
end
um yeah it wasn't actually a big problem
because I think the calculations were
pretty straightforward and they all seem
to be working out for me so
um yeah I had to spend some time Bishop
takes F6 but after that I think the
position kind of played itself pretty
much so yeah after that it was pretty
calm yeah thank you I mean really great
job no seriously very well done I mean
that's also really Mark of a champion
too keeping your nerves in this moment
when you are
facing the clock which is really nasty
and a very sharp double-edged position
rated extremely well in that game just
looking at some of the ladies it looks
like Talia is in deep trouble Arena
crash this has made this uh very uh
powerful move Queen on G5 to H6
and then saying mates on G7 as well as G
h8 squares and frankly I just don't see
a suitable response well rookie seven
yes on the board that's it that's it
perfectly timed yes you know it's a new
fashion to allow your opponent to
Checkmate on we've never allowed that
not in my day never you know we resigned
well in advance of any of any threats of
Checkmate but uh congratulations to
Irina who by the way eight-time Champion
really starting to find her form three
in a row yes absolutely uh hat trick yes
we can see also learn our thoughts who
is doing great photos and which you can
find in Flickr account
absolutely as well as in our social
media and by the way I had gone to
Leonard's site which has
thousands of photos over the ages it's a
really remarkable looking at for example
photos of erusion when he had hair
okay
[Laughter]
this way right now he looks really cool
he's always on his way
if you ask me I prefer a varus like this
I mean he looks really really fancy it's
true it's true it's very very distinct
looks uh
um better over to you uh Christian uh oh
no no no sorry excuse me it was the game
of Jennifer you and Alice Lee excuse me
this uh was a very intriguing moment
right here uh this was the two nights I
remember
Queen takes and there was some sharp
stuff going on at first blush uh we're
not sure who's winning I mean Alice is
ready to play uh the winning move Rook
A8 and thanks to the pin uh that that
would be great but the problem is the
night is hanging uh Rook A8 is met by
Rook takes B4 and Alice would have to
resign so Alice did this really crafty
move I loved it a lot Knight to D3
and said I'm threatening Rook A8
I'm threatening to play Rook A8 but I'm
also threatening to take your Rook yes
so uh right Jennifer said I'll play F5
attacking your queen and ah you know why
she did this I think because let's say
if you take room D3 right away rookie
eight you don't have this check group
history now right they check which you
would like to to do and then take this
Rook on A8 precisely yes but then a
queen is on the sixth controlling these
three squares so maybe she's trying to
get rid of Queen yes so now Queen should
stay on this diagonal exactly we'll
control B3 Rook takes D3 uh sorry for
some reason my okay Rook takes D3 Rook
A8 but look at this material imbalance
that is occurred so two Rooks versus the
queen is one thing
but two Rooks versus the queen at night
no okay
should be winning until you get to this
position you start to realize well wait
a minute uh the King has no Pawn Shield
so uh all white needs to do is set up
one of these you know Rook on the B line
and Rook on the a line and it's mate yes
but still
still defend against exactly but you can
imagine like something like this might
be and this is how white turns the
tables yes okay this is the so but in
the meantime if Alice doesn't play
Knight to B8 you've got to also look at
this moves and things like this so uh
but you know you you're ready to say oh
yeah black is better because of the
Queen of the Night versus the two Rooks
but there are two pawns on Jennifer's
side of the board I do think Alice is to
be preferred but it's not just
easy five night E5 In This Moment yeah
it feels very likely that it's just
probably going to end up in some sort of
a Perpetual yeah okay six right
but at least now we don't have this
Checkmate right so but I have to take
care of my queen
yeah maybe let's try to find something
better yeah exactly 95
it was a oops excuse me
or maybe there is a better no no I liked
your 95. so I could play Rook check
on d8 I mean you're forking my Rook so
one of them have to give a check yes so
how could I do that so if I made for
example check
and I make for example something of this
nature right so I okay Queen takes F5
what else right for example
I can't play Rook D7 so show the the
keys caves right yes you don't want it
probably yeah I don't yeah um it feels
like once the king escapes your queen
and the Knight are going to become
extremely dangerous exactly but how do I
keep the king in the Box let's try to
find a way you don't have time to wear
obviously obviously but I don't know
okay perhaps
I will give you a check on A3 yes okay
at least I keep my king covered on the a
file and now I drop back with the Rook
summer C3 or C1 okay C3 let's go to C3
now I give you checks yeah finally I
found the Perpetual yes that is very
nice so you just keep giving those
checks and I've got it prepared yeah
okay so there is an example where the
two Rooks because the king the black
king doesn't it doesn't have a pawn
Shield you see all of these uh ways that
the Rooks can make perpetuals and the
players have made time control we'll
keep an eye on this holiday game Queen
takes F5 was played and let's jump uh a
question if you don't mind uh uh on your
board with the Fabiano game because uh
our tournament leader is winning with
the black pieces absolutely he seems to
be just about to put the finishing
touches on his opponent after this move
G3 if you go King to E2 and try to stay
like this the problem is that this Recon
G3 also protects the bishopone A3 so I'm
just going to pick up the pawn on A3 I
can even start with Rook takes F3 King
takes F3 and then Bishop takes A3
there's no way you're going to stop the
beat so unfortunately that's completely
losing he played the move Rook to F5
we're expecting the move King to H6 keep
this Rook on the third rank get ready
take on H3 get ready take on A3 as well
there is no way you're going to be able
to find some sort of a Perpetual just
with your rook and the Knight on E7 you
need your king into the attack but
there's uh unfortunately no way to
bypass this third rank activity of other
Rooks that you're going to go King to E2
but there's no King to F3 coming
anywhere in the position I'm going to
pick up your pawns and then I'm going to
promote one of them this one is in the
books guys this one is pretty much over
at this point thank you for that uh
Christian I just I for some reason I've
been expecting us to announce that
Sophie has won our game okay this was
the game with the pawn on G4 and let's
pick up so this is the more or less
a good general you know leads us and
leads her King into battle you know uh
and I thought that this was over and
somehow Rochelle is you know been
fighting fighting and has worked her way
to a position I'm not going to say that
it's great or anything like that but
she's still in the game right yes up to
I'm trying to check the pawn this no yes
yes so it's only one pound down or yes
only one pound down should be winning
should be winning but still
but uh Christian you are you're hosting
a time uh US Women's Champion Arena
crash absolutely Irina congratulations
welcome back uh to the studio it felt
like the results the decisive results
were just about ready to show on your
boards and finally they did you scored a
hat trick you scored the three decisive
results three wins how do you feel right
now and what changed in your play yeah
so well that's the thing nothing changed
at all right it was just a matter of you
know
um playing a little bit better and maybe
getting a little bit luckier
um and yeah and I do like I said I feel
like I've been playing better every
round and uh this game was kind of a
pleasant surprise you know when you get
to attack like that it's kind of
inspiring because you don't win in a
like a routine way but you actually you
know I think G5 was a really interesting
uh Pawn sack going all the way maybe we
can talk about sorry position sorry to
interrupt you Fabiano caruana I just won
his game against El Sean moriada and
extends easily that thought
yeah so when she let me play this move
C5 right I thought okay that's you know
black has delayed developing this Knight
for way too long right she could have
played Knight D7
uh yeah 97.
um okay that's that structure position
yeah of course it's uh it's nice for
whites but you know when she when she
played A5 I was like you know I can
actually do better than that and C5
looks like really interesting because
actually I have Bishop A3 ideas so she
it's very hard for her to kick back with
the queen
now if she takes then that's what
happens in the game right but like in
general like if she goes like Knight C6
and I take right she can't take with the
queen because of this so this little
detail is not helpful for black and if
she takes with a c Pawn I mean I just
thought the position after C4 honestly
was pretty bad and I mean yes it's kind
of playable but like I was even looking
at ideas here like Knight F3 to D2 to B1
to C3 as like the best Square for the
night and just stay on that position
because it's pretty I mean it seems kind
of bad in terms of the pawn structure
for black here
um but what she went for I guess is even
worse yeah like she took on C5 yeah and
then this position was you know quite
quite amazing for white but I I think I
deserve a beating for this F1 move it
was such a bad bad positional move
actually and I I think I just got over
excited about my position like I just
was like oh this looks nice for me but
of course if you just think about the
big picture like you have the center you
have the bishop pair so why my trading
pieces why am I changing the pawn
structure
um yeah I think F4 I wasn't uh in
hindsight wasn't too happy with that but
still even after F4 you do uh keep some
of your advantage and definitely this
very nice center right that became
decisive in the game Knight takes C5 and
then you play this move Bishop to F4
Rook 28 and G4 yeah so let me tell you a
little bit here like I mean I just
realized it wasn't so easy for me to win
with this big sensor right that I'd been
counting on like if I go D4 there's
always Bishop C4
um my Pawn can't really move to D5 and
like
um yes I wasn't sure how I was going to
proceed here so then I was like well let
me try this G4 idea like maybe somewhere
I can play G5 like
um it is kind of like part of the board
where I can do something on and after
she played Knight f8 uh Bishop E3 B6
then I was like again I was kind of
stuck for a move
and and then and then this this idea hit
me like I can just sack the pawn to make
sure the diagonal is always open and G5
is
um under pressure and then I can go in
the center and this is that's actually
probably the best thing that I came up
with in the game because it really
accelerated the win right you can just
tell it like it was a turning point and
after this point like okay somehow the
game went smoothly you know I despite
the computer's evaluation like I never
felt any trouble again in this game you
felt like the pressure is piling up and
your opponent is it was really hard for
her I mean to figure out like you know
what to do with the Knight to protect
the G5 Pawn or nods and and the center
now was kind of Untouchable you know
yeah absolutely and the were there any
critical moments after this one or you
just felt like I mean over here actually
wait one second Christian I was
wondering if I could sag The Exchange I
was like can I just go Rook cf1 but then
I realized you know after Bishop F5 and
pawn takes she always has these F6 ideas
and actually my pawns they could get a
little bit stuck so yeah I have to say
this is very tempting seeing D5 E5 and
F5 yeah I thought that was stylish but
you know then I was like I don't I don't
really need this because I can just move
my Rook
um and and then basically she has a
tough time defending this F7 pawn and
once I take it then it's just like a
matter of you know not blundering
anything and winning with the queen and
the pawns absolutely Irina
congratulations uh three out of three in
the last uh three rounds congratulations
go get some rest and we'll see you in
the remainder of your games thank you
Christian well done well done Arena
three in a row indeed uh turning our
attention to Jennifer you versus Alice
Lee by the way we did not see the move a
knight E5 uh by Alice the one that we we
then thought we would play Rook check
and Rook C3 yes it kind of sour
Perpetual uh occurring instead Alice
took the pawn immediately in Rook B3 now
this was the one thing that I would want
to avoid is black and I'm I'm not saying
that Alice is worse or anything like
that probably a draw is still the most
likely result but with the King now cut
on the a file you know okay Rook C4
obviously I've got a check to deal with
and I'm not going to take that I'm not
going to blunder my Rook but you can see
that you know mates are always uh you
know in the air so after the move Rook
B3 I think the worst is behind Jennifer
draw most likely result but it's it's so
easy uh one bad move one bad slip by
Alice and his Checkmate so uh what to do
here to play not B8 or King A7 King A7
yes yeah I I was thinking Knight C5 just
uh for the moment to guard A6 and you
created a nice trip yes yes yes that
that was that was part and parcel of
Knight C5 is I don't get I don't lose
the Knight and get pinned by Rook B5
because I do have this queen uh H1 idea
but okay uh even yes exactly even here
not Rook B5 sorry Rook B4
and I don't know uh maybe Queen D5 it's
uh it's well it's a three result game
expect to draw the most likely but yes I
I would have preferred the Knight E5 as
opposed to Queen takes F5 but you know
what I have feeling that delicious
planned for victory here at this moment
she definitely thinks that she's better
she's better assistant
how do you make a draw how do I make a
draw okay good question because now you
don't have this um yes a group B6 review
said because B7 is controlled yep so she
defended against both checks on A6 on A4
yep so I'll play Rook to B6 again
keeping the uh and maybe you know to
play Rook to B5 so that I'll I
what I'm trying to do is encouraging you
to make a Perpetual check right at least
always
[Laughter]
but of course this crazy stuff like 19
foreign
Queen F7
probably nothing
scary checks it's just some scary tracks
maybe you can even go King before it all
right let me take that
oh
that's a nice one yeah that's something
that you have to uh be wary of by the
way just a reminder Halloween is coming
up I see in the neighborhood a lot of
the Halloween trick-or-treaters uh
getting ready to scare us uh yes so
these scary uh patterns Rook C3 on the
board by Jennifer we talk about those
you know again chess isn't all about I
play a good move you play a good move I
play a good news it's about nerves yes
it is keeping your nerves in those
critical moments where uh you're worried
you could be worse but you're not sure
you're and uh you're you're still
determined to make a victory despite the
fact that you you have your self-doubts
that's really really tough and this is
one moment right here right now where
both ladies are feeling the butterflies
yes and look at the time
it's almost the same right 21 against 25
minutes it's okay I mean yes they are
they're trying to take care of their
time it's important to have enough of
time to calculate all these tricks and
all these small ideas let me let me get
uh Kristen to weigh in on this game
between Jennifer and Alice because again
I I feel like somehow despite the
material imbalance a draw is probably
the most likely result it feels uh it
definitely feels so right now the
engines are actually do uh prefer a
blackout they do prefer before yeah it
doesn't seem like you have that
Perpetual yet in your back so how do you
set up your Rooks it's it's it's a big
question right now and I'm getting
closer to your kids look at this like
you play rugby three for example yes
just to give an idea
enough one yes
one as well and they six I'm just
protected
yeah B1 is a scary check so let's try to
go Rook A6 Rook B6 sure but now maybe I
can go Knight to C4 no you don't even
play Queen B1 wow I can if I want to but
I think this move or maybe even King to
A7 oh check this out goodness there's no
Rook to A6 unless this is some sort of a
draw right do you have enough time to
exchange the last Pawn yes I probably
not I have doubts I have doubts no no I
think you're losing this one so Knight
E4 is the best move was by the way the
move Rook B3 Jennifer was that because
now we can double guess every move it
seems Rook to B4 was the best move this
was the best yeah that was the move that
we were I I like to keep the king uh cut
on the B line yeah yeah okay Rook C3
maybe a slight mistake and you're saying
by the way Knight E4 moving away from
your king not easy not easy uh yeah I
would get really I would be like super
surprised away from getting checkmated
right right I think we've seen a check
on F1 and can't wait to immediately
okay uh that was not the 94 variation
you proposed not the Knight E4 not not
yet so let's see how she's going to
follow it up with maybe Queen to F7 she
just displayed queen of seven you
mentioned these quote scary checks
but okay I I'll step away from the scary
check with King B1 invite a perpet
is that what you think so I don't think
you want to go to A1 that's for sure
right oh yeah it doesn't look maybe
Knight B3 and maybe there's something
going on yeah why allow that I I agree
with you B1
it's important yes no you cannot win The
Rook like that no but at least I can go
back now I can go Queen to F5 and I
think you're almost forced to go King to
A1 now King A2 Queen D5 I think I'll
pardon me oh that's um that's a wake up
yeah I have to go a one yes for example
Queen to A1 and now I can do the same
thing Knight to E4 aha I think it's the
same position right yeah you can return
to the Knight E4 line that you proposed
a moment ago
ah
wow uh great great stuff by the way it
looks like
um I wanted to say that Rue Yang Yan uh
is completely winning
she she had essentially won all of
White's king-site structure and oh boy
uh I'm not quite sure what uh
it's not actually hoping for some crazy
stalemate no it's just that she's
getting mated it's it's not there yeah
it's not there not so great event for
noises so far yes no no it's not been a
good struggling uh another Victory by
the way for the black pieces uh should
Ru Yang Yan win
and uh again well Jennifer is the big
news what is happening to everybody's
favorite uh
history
what's the stalemate idea
I know it's check oh my gosh I'm trying
to see some kind of stalemate with Rook
G8 and another who comes because it's
still not today so I think the King was
on H4 right yes if the king yes there
was a moment when King was on this floor
you can take only three
four of them yes but but it somehow I
started to see here like rookie three
Rook takes and then Rook d8 uh it
happened
yes and these uh championships I've seen
the crazy Road the crazy yeah
unfortunately even here
I think it's her first win but I don't
want it is her first win yeah
but for najib as you're saying just not
her tournament in the first uh sixth
round and uh over to you uh Christian as
we have a guest in studio we do have a
guest that is definitely not on his uh
first uh victory that is Fabiano caruana
Fabiano congratulations with the black
pieces a big important result how do you
feel and how did you strategize this
game
well I've played a very random line
which I
knew a little bit I mean I didn't really
know much I didn't know how to prepare
this opening because elshon isn't really
an E4 player but he was playing in this
tournament so I figured he has some idea
in mind
uh but I he had no games in this line so
I just decided to play it without were
you trying to get a fighting game out of
the opening yeah I mean I I think it's a
very risky opening Choice uh and I
didn't know what to do after Bishop G3 I
knew it was some sort of line I just
didn't know like I thought Knight of six
he'll take and play E5 and get a
slightly better position exactly yeah
and I didn't really feel like going for
something which he knows where it's a
tiny bit better for it so I decided to
get creative which um was certainly not
good
not good okay I mean I I don't imagine
that uh
playing Bishop B7 Bishop D7 is very good
for black
followed by E5 but then he shocked me I
mean Bishop G4 I was a
and I think this one was the uh I mean
I thought white is slightly better with
some kind of Castle short or something
95 yeah something along those lines but
black has a solid position
um and then Bishop G4 nearly loses on
the spot
because after take H5 only move is Queen
H3 and if G5 only moves F3 not to lose
the queen
um of course that's the queen not the
bishop well I guess you can play Bishop
H4 if you really want to yeah but uh if
you don't want to lose material F3 is so
it's it's I understood he was trying to
trade the Bishops at any cost but to put
the queen on H3 and take so much time
doing so it felt like the very very
risky and incorrect Choice and then I
thought it was completely unclear
later on I mean it was a very
complicated position
how would you come up with this plan
Bishop G5 Rook to H6 well Bishop G5 is
to stop one Castle it's pretty simple uh
his King on the king side is a little
bit vulnerable
um because the queen is there it's all
his pieces are sort of crowded around
together and he can't move the queen if
he would get castle on King B1 I think
he would have a fine position he could
later Play Bishop two and G3 and with
the King on uh G1 you never want to play
G3
so I was happy to get the king there and
what about Rook to H6 what was the idea
behind it uh sorry okay if we go back a
move and say he I play Knight F6 instead
then F4 and I wasn't sure about this I
saw in various moves here like Knight H7
some crazy stuff fg5 Knight G5 Queen G4
HG Queen G3 I didn't want to allow this
because it felt a bit easier to play for
white he plays Rook D1 then he gets all
the files
um although maybe it's also kind of
unclear uh so F4 I just didn't want to
allow
so Rook H6 is forcing the bishop back
and now he no longer achieves that four
so easily it's still one of his main
ideas to get F4 even at the cost of a
pawn sometimes
um so I think what we did was normal
Rook D1 Queen C7 Knight C1
uh A3 very questionable I thought
um I think that was yeah the engine was
saying as well so instead of A3 I was
thinking
um yeah I was thinking like Knight one
E2
and then I'll probably play either 97 or
King G8 some move like that
let's say King G8 and he can play A3
it's exactly the same plan but now I
didn't have this Knight A5 resource
let's say I play like 97. now here he
just has B3 or three and the Knight on
C3 is protected so let's say 97 Rook D3
some kind of Rook d8 Rook I like this
type of position
um it just felt equal to me yeah I
didn't see what I'm doing I also didn't
see what he's doing I would be a bit
more comfortable with black because I
really think white has like no ideas
here you can move the knight from C3 you
can't move the knight from E2 and your
Rooks are very nice but
but also and it's pretty difficult to
get the queen back in into place well
yeah like the only way is F4 at some
point which comes at the cost of a pawn
so it's not easy at all but still black
has to find some sort of idea here yeah
so A3 I I thought was very very slow and
I took the chance to play Knight A5
um yeah and here I thought like 94 is a
huge mistake yep I thought like F4 was
very unclear ef4
um and yeah fish before 93 so uh so
Queen F5
and I was wondering about this Rook H5
here
Knight F4 G6 I thought Queen G6
and uh if FG then 96 and Knight C7 yeah
um so it seems to be so I wasn't sure
Rook H5 or Rook G6 it was but I decided
I'll I'll take that choice because I'm
no longer risking uh and I'll just like
let's say Knight F4 take take
um and in W2 then uh Queen D6 which I
guess is still kind of better for black
but
I mean I wasn't worried you know it's
clear that I'm the only one pressing
here but I still thought the position
was quite unclear and after this Knight
C4 night before I wasn't sure Queen C8
or Knight B2 I mean queen C8 I think it
was the right decision to get into this
yeah it looked very practical but then I
messed it up later I thought I I already
thought the game's over
at what point and then like yeah I just
thought like after A5 because after A5
if he doesn't play Knight A2 which I
thought was a good try
um yep that let's say he plays Knight D5
the problem for him is like take take
Knight to E3
he has to take or he loses an exchange
King H1 Rook C2 Rook A5
and he's getting mated
um yeah like Rook G6 there's still Rook
A8 King E7 Knight C3
but I think that even if I play like
King D7 here or something yeah 95 Bishop
D4 yeah he's just getting made it slowly
so so this is what I thought might
happen but instead he went for this uh
very nice exchange flag I mean it's a
good practical chance probably the only
chance yeah he has
I don't know like yeah I definitely
messed up but I wasn't sure how to play
this I mean
and then Bishop d8 it's like an
extraordinary opportunity no not not
here but a move before instead of Rook
D3 we were talking about this after the
game uh the difference is that if um B5
now Bishop F6 GF Knight D5
uh he attacks the bishop so there's no
Rook C2 yeah it's on about 97 so much
but the bishop is also attacked so if he
had done this I mean I'm still better
but uh but really messed it up not that
easy after Bishop to d8 yeah yeah so
this was a was very sloppy to allow this
uh but he did it the move later when it
was very um
where it was just a move too late
Bobby's still seven rounds to go but
you're extending your lead uh at the top
how are you feeling about your chances
right now or are you even thinking about
that championship
no well how can I play it without
thinking about it I mean I'm I'm quite
happy so far it's been going well
uh I can't say that my games are
brilliant but still the results are very
good
um I was even happy with like my game
yesterday not yesterday but the day
before against Wesley because I didn't
have many ambitions
um but still I post him some serious
issues I thought and uh he was very
close to getting in trouble
so it felt like even if I'm not getting
anything out of the opening I'm still
able to pose my opponent some problems
which is a good sign
um and other players are a little bit
uneven so far but we'll see it's still a
long way to go guys enjoy the
conversation yeah I have a question I
mean Fabiana you are local here you know
we know that you live not far away from
the club and these days especially that
U.S championships are happening uh I
recognize More Often by people on the
streets and like how is your life these
days
well I I got recognized but I can't say
it's because of me
I think it's more because of Huns I mean
I get stopped off and then uh asked
about Beats
it happens more often than I'd I'd like
to to admit
um but yeah it seems like chess is
pretty popular these days sometimes
people notice me because I'm uh I guess
a local player but more often than not
it's uh
it's about the Cur the current ongoing
situation yeah that's what I thought a
quick question for you Fabby uh in this
U.S championships we're seeing a lot of
draws very very very tough hard to win
games and then suddenly
it's like you know the sky's open and
you're you're winning game after game
how does that
is that what what what what what makes
uh sudden a rampage of Victories when
everybody's having a heart's log
well I think a lot of his circumstance
you know some tournaments even if you're
not playing poorly you just don't get a
chance some tournaments uh everyone's
giving giving things to you so it's just
important to get those those victories
at the right moment those opportunities
at the right moment
um but yeah chess is very much like that
that sometimes you go a long period
without
any opportunities with your opponents
playing brilliantly and not giving you
any chances and sometimes
um very strong players collapse for
unexpected reasons so um that's just the
way chess is it balances out in the end
but uh but that can explain the current
you know uh pot streaks that people have
or or collapses that people have
um it's not always in your hands I mean
you you
try to control it as much as you can but
very often
um I mean you still need help from your
opponent to win games if your opponents
ever make mistakes then then you'll
never win a game so it's uh that's
that's just how it is
very good luck yes absolutely uh good
luck uh turning our attention to the
game of Lavon and darus the one
remaining game it looks like another
black Victory is in store uh and that
would make three black victories in the
open
um Lavon earlier was an exchange down
played the move d4 hoping that his uh
connected passers in the center could
offer some compensation for the exchange
but darush has played it very well just
saying Rook takes F2 you've got your
pawns but I'm about to get mine as well
I'm about to play G4 Rook takes G2 and
after D5 G4 we have this uh situation on
the board Rook H1 and I thought that
black was for Choice let's just put it
that way that uh the Rooks
are doing being very very very good for
darush but that's not actually three
actually I thought the game will would
have would finish really a long time ago
but yeah it felt like yeah yeah
one managed somehow to stay in the game
I mean it seemed like that he will lose
there will be some checkmates or
something like that because his scheme
was actually floating around as well uh
this move uh G3 by the way uh sets up a
very nasty idea if uh Lavon plays a move
like uh C6 and G2 is really really fast
we can see that Rook F1 is on tap so we
do expect this game to go in favor of
darusha let's just say that hold on I I
wanted to go sorry I was in the wrong
game Jennifer versus Alice what's
happening here what's happening
Alice's Pawn Palace
Queen F7 check and Jennifer said
you want to play for a win I will play
King A3 I'm not backing up and 94 and
you're laughing though what's going on
in this game uh of course I'm laughing I
think she cannot play for a win there's
no way she can play for a win there's no
way she what why I mean I I don't see
how white can play for a win in this one
you don't see how I can play Forever
it's a threat is
and go into that end game so let's see
uh could Jennifer be thinking about
um okay so you want what if I go Knight
D2 now yeah that's the problem right I'm
more afraid that the Knight it could go
to be one check I'm giving some checks
some yeah some naughty checks for sure
so very very naughty checks
um
Queen B3 is also on tap I mean you have
to be careful with that information yeah
exactly so okay so
let's say I just yeah I just chill I'll
go Rook to D to stop your night I hope
you have money too actually still
because Queen F3 is coming maybe no but
I have Rook C3
I was so yeah I found it it doesn't work
and Anastasia even this one is not
working we're going with the King wow
wow and I don't have any chips so uh
now I can believe the two place will win
them in I don't know I can see I can see
how things could go wrong let's just put
it like that I remember I was playing
with Jan Timon where I had this very
strange material imbalance as well of
two Rooks versus queen and Bishop but
also his King was not with a shield of
thanks to that the bishop had to
um block checks and it wasn't an
effective Bishop so I could make a draw
with this two Rooks versus queen and
Bishop again if if there was a Pawn on
B7 we wouldn't be discussing it would be
just play on one goal and Alice would be
uh winning but because the black king
has no protection
there are they're easily quite a number
of ways I could make a Perpetual check
and just kind of as you said you know
Rook C7 might even get it yeah it might
even get me more than a pipette
definitely keeping an eye on this one
and by the way uh more games in the
ladies uh Sabina versus
um
Megan Lee Megan is actually doing great
in the tournament and she was one of the
leaders for a long time besides herself
for second place right and she saved
that incredible game against Serena
crush it was a really nice uh Megan
looks great here guys she's completely
winning queen queen versus rook and
Bishop but even worse she's got uh
ideas of H5 and G4 and White's King will
come under a checkmating attack thanks
to the power of the queen and the pawns
so she looks very good Sabina this would
be bad news for Sabina sabina's like
been on a on a tumble run she lost the
previous game yes also and this one
doesn't look good exactly I only see one
reason why Megan is still thinking right
now about H5 and then G4 so let's go H5
what's the reason
before and now something like Bishop B4
and hope that I'm checkmating you
and you cannot touch my Bishop somehow
is that true no
nobody believes you
checks was Queen the problem is your
king can't hide so let's go to G1
okay I'm trying to hide yesterday are
you trying to hide let me do my best
right okay the best here so I cannot go
to H2 because you go G3 and probably you
made me right that's a mate
G3 if I go up you go Queen H1
if I go King G1 you go Queen F2 Queen H2
yes so that's amazing that's clear I
have to drop back right to G1 okay
now how do I uh how do you stop this
idea Rook C8 right what you play King d8
well King d8 I go E7 King D7 King D7 and
I hope I have some groups well if you're
gonna do that let's check yes toss in
the check first
yeah
E7 the good news is the pawn is not
going to promote after a move like Rook
C7 that is a very good point yeah yeah
right that looks really great if it's
the same idea I think that's the way
yeah and then uh we're we're going to
get in uh one of our pawns is going to
be advancing it's going to be causing
mating patterns to magically appear and
in the other game between Rochelle
and again this was a game if Rochelle
saves this
uh I'm gonna sign up for her her courses
uh because she was really really in a
deep distress
um
she still lives I think like Bishop's
history and dito
I was even thinking you could
no no no
you know just kind of like uh
because the bishop usually does such a
great job at protecting against
um
passers I can put my Bishop on D4 don't
need to spend even time to get this Pawn
right exactly and then the king could
end up getting trapped so
um maybe I even start with Bishop to D4
here hold on I think it's white to move
pardon me so first of all you have to
stop the pawn
and yeah maybe just Bishop D4 and King
D5 should be winning
uh for uh Sophie but she's made her life
a lot more difficult I'm sure she had it
in the back or I think we have to go to
the to the Darius game all right what
happened there I'm not sure how easy it
is anymore really
because he played G3 right I yeah he
went all the way there's a lot of things
that have been going on yes of three
so okay keep going
I stopped no I cannot I have to uh
refresh okay sorry
I was afraid to propose even this idea
and now oh this Holy Spirit only has one
minute that's the thing that's the thing
I'm looking for oh my gosh so C6 I have
three this is seven yes I thought about
yes this one but I thought it's not
working do you think and Rook D1
and Bishop D4 very calm movies yes stop
in G1
unbelievable so I'm still I'm sure he's
still winning but yeah I'm not sure why
are you so sure but how do you win this
why are you so sure uh this is it's
getting crazy I mean on a good day I'm
moving my king so that I can threaten
um
B7 so I think once you move the king I
go Rook F7 I have to do it right so you
start with what H5 or H5 or King G6
it's winning and now you have to 10
seconds you have to have to find them
wow okay now with this move H5 obviously
you want to go H4 H through HDM yeah so
I've got to go King D2 I can't start
with the desirable D7 yes because well
yes okay so I get out of check King to
D2 now I'm threatening D7 and wins so
for example you take on oh no you have
to go back I'm anticipating yeah
seven but the iPhones are coming yes so
now maybe it's time Rook G1 H4 for
example right
okay but how do you make progress
now maybe now Rook D7 and Rook takes C7
oh that's nasty oh oh yeah okay it's
really really unpleasant oh oh oh Rook
D7 which means I don't have time
to I have to start with Bishop E5 no
hold on just a second I S no Bishop E5
if I start with Bishop E5 let's go H4
King
but you're not are you threatening
anything right now
I can even start with Rook F2 and Rook
F1
that might be a problem as well Rook F2
and Rook F1
yeah Rook F2 that's that's nasty sorry
sorry sorry I have to I have to be more
clever here for Lavon
um
King C3
right
H4 I keep pushing yeah yes Bishop here
so the idea is when you play H3 I want
to take on G3
no no no no F1
D7 and I think we check on C7 and then I
take on D1
oh that's so nice oh oh that's so nice
you give up and you what a geometry you
control everything yes and now you
control so d8 square that and by the way
something like that is on the board we
no excuse me sorry this is we're waiting
for King D2 yeah oh so darush is it's
about the clock though how many no
they've already made the second time 37
seconds he has so he's on increment yes
it's already the second thing of course
so of course yeah it's not easy at all
for him
and only one what has 30 minutes yes yes
his only hope was to try to make uh his
opponents complicated
playing on the increments I tried to go
and win against lewand even the winning
position yes
and that will be definitely a heartbreak
for uh Levon
yeah
okay because he didn't get pretty close
to saving this one he did okay we were
expecting this game to finish like an
hour actually like an hour and a half
ago truly I cannot understand the book
of seven for example yeah well there's a
difference the difference is that I'm
not walking into Rook take C7 so it does
mean that against Rook F7 I can play
Rook G1 and a moment ago when when my
king was on D2
Rook take C7 was a killer so H4 was
played H4 so what kind of the ideas
maybe that now you don't threat D7
exactly yes so H4 he has time to play it
four right no D7 Rook takes check so
that was the problem of putting the King
on C2 as opposed to D2
so what is the blanking B3 or what Rook
D1 D7 I mean yes yes a bit Brave and try
something here yes yeah yeah no that
makes a lot of sense yeah I mean at
least maybe some Perpetual check maybe
you'll have couple of Queens on the
board but I will find a way to give you
a check right yeah so for example before
you take on C8 G1 quid and then Queen
with five and actually
as you say a couple of queens and by the
way and the king is in a Perpetual oh
boy oh boy yes I like it I like it I
mean but I think and your clock is
ticking down to 30 seconds he has to
play it fast
just play oh my God oh my gosh yes
you're losing of course but that's part
of the Dilemma in chess right you don't
know that you're losing you don't know
for sure that you you feel that things
are failures but you try not to think
about it that much no you're also
thinking about sure I might be losing
but what if I actually have a chance so
then you spend more time and then your
opponent has time to calculate on your
time yes so you have to play fast but
that's the Dilemma you can never well
you can know but you can never be sure
about your perfected strategy right
well King B3 would be oh that would be a
real shock maybe there is another maybe
bishop G1 move I don't know what what
else he's thinking about like Bishop G1
I don't know well that still doesn't set
up for D7 that's why I love your move
Rook B3 it can be three
um
I guess I just have to go Rook F7 right
yeah but can't you do something
yesterday I thought but maybe G1 no no
well I'm happy to give up my bit one
yeah but easy for me to say I'm happy to
give up my Bishop Bishop C5 take and
what do you play here RX is real oh
or maybe move my king because I thought
only D7 yes and you go here wow uh we do
Let me refresh my board I apologize I
promise to come right back he played
with the semester he's closing Bishop to
C5 so once again threatening D7 D7 and
there's no check because and then darush
very quickly played Rook F5 threatening
to take the bishop followed by capturing
the pawn
Bishop takes A7 still
there's no wow this this is turning out
to be an incredible race
and it still feels like anything's
possible now I think I can just go H3 or
Rook D7 no you're not threatening to go
D7 that's still not threatening to go to
you're absolutely right apologies
free or somewhere yeah now finally all
right H2 H2 and whenever you go D7 I go
Rook at Faith King G6 whoa wow where did
that come from I'm not sure about that
King G6 that seems a bit
why did I need my king my king was
that is an industry
wow King G6 help help us out Christian
why that move I'm pretty sure it's still
winning but it's not the best movie in
the position because H3 was really scary
right h3h2 yeah
why did he need King G6 well I mean when
you have nine seconds on the clock you
start seeing ghosts yeah you start
ghosting it that is absolutely true so
what now can be three is it is it the
move or something else well again you're
desperate
The Rook takes but Bishop B6 Maybe
I mean same ideas King B3 you just
you're I mean it's all about playing D7
I believe
and what if I go
still H3 right okay H3 D7 and what if I
go to Cafe okay which Rook yeah the one
that doesn't allow you to get a queen
okay well you mean that one
yes yes
okay
pause but for because of the move King
G6 yes you got this idea Rook takes C7
right and do you want and I think that
end game should be losing
I know but this is crazy you're just yes
oh my gosh my table base just popped up
and said I'm winning oh boy
um crazy crazy it's a one tempo game yes
it really is and that move King G6 was
starting to make a difference luxury
okay so this is the position with uh
maybe my move Bishop B6 is wrong King B3
what you wanted
Sophie has one
and I think it's her first Victory as
our Wild Card entrance as to the
organizers thank you for your trust yes
let me reward your trust with the win
so we are back to the game yes no it's
the most exciting game for sure right
now well but Jennifer's game I'm still
anxious to see what's going on
that one is going to go on for a while
we should stay with this one yes now
that he has only seconds on his with
those 30 seconds well one one player is
39 seconds the other has 27 minutes
we could be waiting waiting waiting for
the 27 minutes to elapse so King G6
strange last move
yes
otherwise
look at how quickly Lavon is playing
Rook D2 wow why not D7 just to
understand uh D7 I will take and then
there is I I I take on
C7 first ah no but the Rook takes and
then I take on D7 ah yeah I got it you
got you take all my phones and you
promote yourself so just wait for myself
to include the audience so D7 looks
great until you see this is Jack yes and
the bishop is distracted from the
protection of the G1 Square then you
take and when you recapture The Rook
that is when I promote the pawn and I
win the game it's a funny uh position
because you are dreaming about giving
both of your roofs for the two parts
exactly that's why King moved to G6 now
I realize that there is no check on D7
yes yes yes sir it's very deep deep
understanding
G6 it's a prophylactical move
now you can take on D7 how do I say it
this is alien chess beyond my
understanding of course King F5 by the
way the king is a marvelous marvelous
blockader uh it means that if I ever get
my king to E6 and D7 these pawns you can
forget about them they're never going to
be threatening uh whatsoever
so he's saying go ahead you're welcome
to take one Pawn that King E6 and I've
still got
uh connected past pawns I don't
understand that my deal with the
industry was better at least two checks
I mean all the time the problem with
this position is the drug c7s was Czech
okay he takes on G2 at least
absolutely say you were you were right
but just I mean that it was a little bit
different from what was happening and I
would play King E6 and say okay
correct not King Jeep King G4 is too
exciting King E6 King D7 and I have
never ever
be worried anymore by these uh pastors
but kudos to Lavon for making uh
difficult it just looked like darush was
going to cruise to an easy win and that
certainly was a big surprise Bishop to
C5 yes
because simply it was not only about
King D7 but also King D6
it's over now
Rook takes C7 and
you're winning the bishop as well
so I would be delighted to sacrifice a
rook for two pawns and a bishop
absolutely
that's it yeah you're absolutely right
that's that's game that's the game yeah
yeah I have a feeling my kingdom was
belonged to obesity
[Laughter]
but Chris I never just can tell us the
evaluation
or a chance for white no no no so maybe
there would be some difference no
now Darius actually walked a very uh
tightrope but he managed to get the
other side
wow so he takes a game
King is we can give three but you don't
need to worry anymore these past pawns
uh do uh the job by themselves actually
no uh
I think an easy way is to just go look
on the first track I Look to C1 and then
h3h3
uh
walk around and
make it as easy as possible yes yes
two extra funds and right I can win it
they can even remember this phrase we
used to say yes Bobby would have no
chance
and also Darius actually has a lot of
time right now a lot of time after those
Rook takes E7 Rook day seven Rook C5 a
minute and 30 seconds now down to his
last 20 seconds but if he finds Rook F5
the game is over I think so too uh okay
this also works before
you can go wow came to F5 yes
one more Chicken King for well just a
second
he has ideas Rook check and kimchi for
you
okay I would have been reluctant myself
personally to allow the king even though
this is a winning ending uh you know to
allow the king to get all the way back
to G1 I like Rook F5 a lot but actually
there are some still made ideas here
right yes
I'm not kidding I I I was I believe it
was Moscow in 1994 and the Olympiad
Alex you're malinski first board was two
pawns down two connected past pawns and
he defended it uh in such a tricky way
that somehow he managed to make a draw
there are moments when uh it's easy to
mess it up
of course you are not obliged to take
the stroke but unfortunately to give you
an example right King H1 yeah this was
his voice like H3 and Rook H2
I think H3 yeah of course but history
has to be waiting so of course but
there's even even after H3 so let's say
you go H3 King G1 and then H2 you can
get one
maybe not King H1 because of Rook F1
okay yeah okay but you can go King G2
and now Rook to F2
and now King H1 and hope that yeah
well there's hope there's some hope
it's a 50 50. you can go Rook F1 and
check with two moves right or you could
take a whole Rook for free
that might be problematic yes what to do
all right so what's the mechanism here
how do you win
are you just simply going
h3h2 and then King H3
I think H3 uh is well let's say the most
simple but
uh funnily enough I always thought I was
always thinking that you would be
putting the so there are some moments
you even play Rook F1 check right
and I think now H2 is probably
game
no but you're going You're
making stairs steps towards but I have
to I have to at some point you have to
you you have to go H2 you can't go King
G2 check and excuse me check and King H3
but the problem is if you wait well
you're not waiting very long
you can try I mean
if the Rook wouldn't be on the board
that would be a stalemate right right
there's no way to give it unfortunately
yeah so maybe we can move to another kid
yes I think we should see them well
because we've stayed for so long we're
invested we are enjoying this moment
it's like uh my friend Jeremy Selman he
and I share uh uh a love for Samurai
movies and we recommend various movies
to one another and he said yes sir the
most amazing movie I ever watched was
Shaolin Soccer you have to see Shaolin
Soccer it's unbelievable it's the
greatest movie it's the greatest movie
ever so I watch this movie for 30
minutes it's the worst movie ever the
worst movie ever it is then I watched it
for 60 minutes and how I'm invested the
CBS yes and I wanted to kill him so I
called him up I said Jeremy that was the
worst movie ever he says yes I know
so he tricked you
she wanted to torture you right truly it
was like what owl in soccer even the
name should have been a giveaway I mean
but such an idiot
I'll never get those two hours back
they're lost yes they're lost
sorry we have some moves here
so we're invested we have to see
the end here
um King F3 is a little bit of a surprise
okay it doesn't spoil anything of course
but uh
what could I do yeah King E2 is a
blunder Rook takes G3 that would be uh
oops
so
hmm
well I think he'll just come back
king
um yeah king of 14 G4
something of that nature
right and then maybe Rook D3 and king of
three if that was his great idea yes
well you can also go
but uh yeah even look F2 is not working
in some lines you take with the pawn
I tried to make it yeah I was about to
ask is he trying to play something like
this
[Music]
so bad
but
it's kind of like a funny way of so
maybe you can start with King F1
actually
won King F1 yeah you give a check so he
did go King F2 and you want to go King
F1 yeah
King you want
King E3 again he's threatening me yeah
so he has to play like check or will be
one okay check and repeat and now King
YouTube now King and I will exchange the
rules at some point that's very Rook of
one clinical I like that yes
that's the best movie in the position
for sure just for fun it's so
all the way up to this point you might
as well try your last chance Last
Chance Saloon yes
this is where yes okay he resigns yes
wow uh okay I didn't see this disaster
coming for Lavon not at all uh again
he's uh two losses and no victories
let's quickly uh rush to the lady
section and to see Jennifer versus Alice
because
they seem to be enjoying themselves and
Jennifer's King got all the way up to A4
yes and her pawns up to B4
and she's playing for victory she wants
to promote this home I'm not sure she's
playing for a week I have no idea what's
going on here um
isn't black for choice now Black's King
is a lot safer remember when the pond
was back on B2 and we had perpetuals yes
we had a rook on C3 a rook on A3 we had
a lot of Perpetual we don't have those
for pets anymore but maybe after Rook C5
and the other one
as we try to figure this out we're going
to turn to Christian with guest in
studio thank you Yasser we are with
Sophie Maurice Suzuki uh who won her
first game in this tournament Sophie a
difficult start for you three losses but
finally after the rest day you came
re-energized and won a brilliant game
how do you feel right now
finally finally
hey I actually played good chess
you did indeed uh take us through the
game actually did you prepare a lot
yesterday how did you spend your rest
day
um I spent it trying to motivate myself
to prepare and failing for the most part
um I think I just ate too much food as I
always do and
I don't know like I I did I did
eventually get myself to do a little
prep
um
which didn't actually happen on the
board in this game so I was mostly just
winging it for the opening phase of this
game were you prepping a lot at the
beginning at the onset of this
tournament and things were not working
well and you felt like you need to
change something
um well none of my opponents were going
into my prep so I don't know I kind of
just
got less and less motivated especially
since I wasn't winning games so
but you definitely took down Rochelle in
this one take us through the critical
moments of this one
she was super aggressive with this
smooth G4
yeah I know that G4 is an idea but not
sure if
I I knew it was an idea with some Bishop
D6 line I wasn't sure if it was an idea
here but it seemed it seems to be
um it seems to be a thing according to
the database because there are games not
many but there are some some high level
games cards and carvanov iruga versus
Wesley so it has been played before
how did you assess this one and how
would you uh
come up with your idea in the game
uh well I was kind of just like
happy that like my opponent was making
um was was playing really aggressively
and like trying to make stuff happen so
I could also make stuff happen
um
Bishop B4 the idea of this move is
to me G5 with Knight E4
um like I I could
now this now 94 is really effective here
so I thought Bishop B4 was a better move
than like I don't know Bishop D6 or
something makes a lot of sense yeah she
played Bishop D3 C5 take on C5 Knight C6
sacrificed the pawn and uh now you took
the pawn back
but you have the bishoper and she
castled then yesterday at this point was
asking who is Rochelle's coach because
you cannot short Castle in play the move
G4 you cannot combine those ideas were
you
um as confused as we were as well
more or less I don't know I mean it's
also like what does white do because
castling queenside is technically
possible but also doesn't look very good
and what other moves does white make
because
I don't even know like your g-pawn is
you're not really in a position to pawn
storm me
um so
yeah I'm not really sure what else white
could do castling either way seems like
the only options to develop both the
Rooks but like foreign
doesn't seem like he's going anywhere
and tell us where do you feel like
you're pretty much have this one in the
back
you got the pawn
you got into this very very favorable uh
end game
it felt like you're on your way to
winning it did you feel like you let any
of your advantage go at any point or was
just smooth sailing or all throughout I
was pretty happy with my position like
all throughout I don't know if I could
have done something better I
I have a feeling that like when I look
at this game afterwards it's gonna it's
gonna say something like the engine's
probably gonna say that like I had a
better option I you know my technique
was not the best but
it was good enough so yeah Sophie
congratulations a big first victory for
you still seven rounds to turn this
event around we'll be seeing you in the
remainder of your games
thank you uh congratulations as well
Sophie uh definitely nice to get your
first win yes exactly the U.S
Championship
um uh Megan Lee also doing very very
well as she is winning uh cruising to
Victory I want to say in her game with
Sabina and this game of Jennifer you and
Alice that really defies uh
understanding but uh Jennifer's fans
will be pleased to know that with this
last move Rook A5 she's setting up uh at
least Perpetual at least a perpetual and
maybe you know like she's thinking like
I can uh
yes sorry uh right here maybe she's
thinking that well just a second just
what are you going to do
what are you going to do
and with a win
Alice could take over Louise but but
okay six is not isn't it
if you go night back I've got at least a
perk also a check but in that case I
think Arena thanks to three victories in
a row will actually have caught up with
Jennifer who made a first draw on the
tournament yes and we have a gas
question we do indeed we are with a man
of the hour here in Saint Louis Darius
verch after an amazing Victory against
Levon aronian Darius first of all
congratulations how do you feel after uh
taking down such a strong opponent tired
happy and tired
yeah how is the game from your
perspective it felt like he was trying
to take you out of the opening early on
it's very complicated honestly you don't
know what was going on for the majority
of the game
I mean I don't know honestly like I know
that I was worse out of the opening
that's for sure and then I guess he got
to over to ambition at some point and I
took over and then my technique was
probably I'm for sure was not the best
but I guess it was sufficient and he
played this move H3 uh yeah actually
this was I mean
yeah like this move I mean it seems like
it's just harmless but in reality it's
not easy to react because like normal
normally that goes to play with E5 but
the NC text D5 cxd5 net B5 is of course
an issue like typical typically in this
position that's why he played Rook C1
earlier to have Knights uh yeah and then
Bishop B8 there is not only Bishop A3
but it's also Queen c297 ideas I'm not
sure whether you include numbers
or or not
but in either case I think it's
dangerous for me because my sister is
coming yeah and e494 always so it just
makes no sense so I think he's doing
very well here and honestly I want to
play with B6 I really want to play with
B6 here but CTX D5 again was a problem
for me if C takes d59b5 again is a
problem and a similar ideas pretty much
so if he takes div 95 I don't want to
play of course but if he takes D5
the Knight D4 are for the problem and I
calculate some weird weird lines like C5
neither five for instance and let's say
Bishop B8 let's say or something just
for instance and I'm thinking Knight
takes D5 works that takes effect Queen
G4 other than miscalculated something
but I guess it wins let's see maybe
three yes yes that's Checkmate in three
yes that's what I thought that's what I
saw okay this definitely works yeah
that's why I mean I I don't have to play
Bishop B8 and I don't have to take on D5
even but all right uh Bishop E5 was a
move but I thought I'm worse here yeah
if I just thought I'm worse here before
yeah I just looked towards to me so for
this reason here I mean I just sort of
you know I didn't know what to do sir I
couldn't understand what my plan should
be if I can play E5 I can play B6 what
am I supposed to attack on C4 and pop
idea that was that if he takes bxc4 I
play E5 and then I get my knight to C5
Rook E8 maybe Queen E7 which comes to F5
um I think it's a normal
interesting position so you aren't
actually worried I wasn't with his job I
was not about to worry about G4 now got
it but he played Bishop X4 was just
correct uh B5 now we got some meron like
structure and he plays with H4 which is
good I think uh H6 and Knight G5 is
probably too ambitious because C5 I
think solves about my problems I think
and I think you're right in your
assessment as well yeah here we have to
take the Knight I thought and only
foreign
G3 uh it's E5 Knight C3 and it was a
disposition but I thought that should be
good here yep
um yeah okay engine the engine confirms
yeah C4 B4 maybe you want some Queen B6
ideas yeah I mean I wasn't sure about
before because we can do the live scores
but okay sound position here I also like
okay I take the pawn queen hd5 and for
sure I'm not worse here uh uh yeah as
far as it was sort in a way you know
sort of expecting Rook H3 G3 I don't
know if he if I I don't know I thought
at least I can I can repeat but I don't
know if I can play Queen G6
actually it's possible okay I thought I
couldn't do that too but I wasn't sure I
thought like at least I have a drug yeah
so uh yeah and then I would think of
course but yeah here was getting very
sharp very very sharp and he wins upon
but uh his King is very weak and groups
force in the blunder all right yeah
um
yeah I mean it looks scary for him for
sure like the United four is coming yeah
for the big threat Queen H1 always I can
throw in any moment it's some some idea
rukong G3 is actually all very awkward
so yeah it's just like Queen to C4 might
be four of the ways but even after
Knight to F4 it looks very scary
yeah this is not easy it's really Queen
takes a queen takes the four yeah
okay it's very very difficult very
difficult and if you play this move Rook
to C4 which is a blunder yeah I mean I
didn't really know it's a blunder I just
thought Queen H1 looks very strong yeah
yeah
and yeah here Queen A3 here I was like
okay it must be winning either four yeah
uh this queen D3 and I'm sure Queen D5
was the best move uh
uh yeah Queen if I was about 25. I was
thinking of Queen D2 maybe I should
could throw in or something but
um okay still better but that's what I
thought it was King because I wanted to
have this have him just have him have
this Pawn on e4 that way uh he cannot
really do like moves like Queen A7 let's
say because we defeat me always that's
why I play Move Queen D5 E4 Queen takes
D2 right now yeah this is this is that's
why I play Queen D5 yeah
um yeah yeah and now F5 I mean this must
be obviously totally winning and my
technique was terrible uh
yeah it'll be seven
stupid move yeah okay this must be
winning but
still not okay here yeah I mean here
basically has lots of practical chances
yeah and uh
I mean I will I will start try to
calculate but then I decided to sort of
trust my God and just take on it to take
these pawns and let's see it was faster
but I thought that you're getting
concerned of course I was getting
concerned that's why I burned so much
time here was after time control and I
wasn't sure like I knew that I should
never lose this of course but whether
it's winning and how easily is this
winning
you know it's it's very difficult to
tell what was the next toughest moment I
guess for you in your calculation
because yeah I mean the assessment
stayed pretty much good for you
throughout the year yeah I mean it's
more like seeing ghosts in here so I
just wasn't sure what I'm calculating
like uh
yeah I mean of course if engine is
easily winning but the board is like
this looks scary simply it doesn't look
scary but a lot of ghosts with this Pawn
C6 and D5 and you know the margin of
blunder of a blunder is very very small
so I was I was concerned about it but
yeah I guess it wins C7 Rook C8 T6 the
attack on G2 and here Rook F1 okay
Bishop D4 H5 is the best move yes okay
H5 is definitely the best and then H4
and then Rook to F5 and I think maybe
King G6 but it's still I just saw that
uh
uh just to interrupt you for a second
this one did finish in a draw
Alice seems to have been better but she
couldn't complete the win never mind no
the game still goes that is not a draw
no they have to make an extra repetition
they were got it yeah
yeah now it's a draw
let's keep going with the analysis yeah
yeah so I play King G6 because I felt
like if I bring my king to the to this
pawns and I always the thing is I
actually can't move back a few moves of
King C2 I thought King D2 is the only
try correct yes it's of Kings to King D2
in order to play D7 but then I play Rook
F7 yes this was the key Point yes uh and
that's why I play H5 because even though
I lose the G2 on my Pokemon H4 response
are blocked and it must be winning of
course yeah I mean it's just too much
right and then you lose the C7 Pawn Yeah
that's why I played H4 you know to not I
will lose probably one of these pawns on
G2 or G3 but not both of them that's why
page for very nicely calculated Darius
congratulations uh a big win for you
guys any questions not at all uh there's
I know how it feels like you want to
beat yourself like you could have won it
earlier or something like that but uh
think of how much excitement
you gave us
the adrenaline something the time
trouble it was wonderful and uh yeah
thank you yeah I mean I'm definitely
happy of course because
um it was a tough game and I'm tired yes
go and enjoy well-deserved rest and uh
well we have all results but again
in the ladies section we had four wins
with the black pieces only one win with
the white pieces Arena crush and here
are our current standings after six
rounds in the history books Anastasia
who the honors so we'll have a tie for
the first place arena crush and Jennifer
York have four and half points out of
six and they're followed by Ellis Lee
and Megan Lee they shared the third
place was four points and then we have
actually types of Brahman alone on on
the fifth position
and in the open section Fabi is really
putting his signature on the 2022 US
championships yeah so look at job is
alone with four and a half sole leader
of the tournament after sixth round
and one point behind him we see Ray
Robson and sam7 with as well as a
Wonderland with three and a half points
and then Wesley saw with three points as
well as salders yes the chasing pack
there Wesley so our defending champion
and uh well uh I had Jennifer
but okay that's a little bit yesterday
we'll be hoping
uh well that's that's not bad that's all
Christian in the open here but how about
this one how about uh yeah yeah I like
your pick okay Jeffrey still do
something you knew something it's unfair
it's unfair
um Christians sum up a very eventful uh
victory-filled round actually it did
feel like there was a lot of blood
spilled in this round and yes coming
after the rest day the players really
wanted to leave their mark on the
tournament and some of them did Fabiano
caruana huge Victory with the black
pieces taking advantage of the
struggling moradi abadi and none of the
players managed to keep Pace with him
right now extending his lead one point
ahead of his nearest rival I have to say
Fabiano right now becomes uh the big
favorite to uh take it all and of course
in the ladies section is so combative at
the top we see the a-time national
champion Irina Crush catching up with
the young Alice Lee but also Jennifer
you lurking there so it's definitely
going to be an exciting last seven
rounds but actually we have so many
rounds no it feels like we've gone
through a tournament already but no we
still have seven rounds ago the last
seven rounds I like that the last seven
and I'm like what what what what
Anastasia is wonderful calling the
action with you it's been a lot of fun
for us thank you I hope the same for our
audience uh join us at the same time
same channel tomorrow as we'll bring you
round
because the last seven I will see you
all tomorrow good night everyone
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited